Morning well, good morning.
In through the nose, out through the mouth.
That's it.
In through the nose and out through the mouth.
God, your hands are getting really low here.
No, no, no, just keep the eyes closed.
Is this normal?
Settle into your sits bones.
早安，早安。鼻子吸气，嘴巴呼气。就是这样。鼻子吸气，嘴巴呼气。天啊，你的手放得太低了。不，不，不，把眼睛闭上就好。这正常吗？坐到你的坐骨上。
Okay?
All right, and feel the spine stacking and the neck rolling.
You don't need to feel my spine.
Wait a second.
Yeah, what is this?
This is a little bit of tension right there, huh?
All right, let's get to an old new smartless.
Smart.
好吗？行，感受脊椎一节节叠起，脖子转动。你不用去感受我的脊椎。等等。没错，这是什么？这里有一点紧绷感，对吧？好，我们来看看一个既老又新的 SmartLess。Smart。
What, were you?
What kind of student were both you two?
Hi, I'm Jason.
Oh, hi, Jason.
Were you guys both smarties?
I don't think so.
I don't make a guess here.
Like bees, you know, solid bees.
什么，你是吗？你们两个以前是什么样的学生？嗨，我是杰森。哦，嗨，杰森。你们俩以前都是尖子生吗？我觉得不是。我在这里猜一下。就像蜜蜂一样，你知道，拿稳稳的B。
Well, in college it was really bad for me because I would always copy.
And so my eyes hurt because my face would be forward,
but my eyes would be looking really hard down to the left.
Right.
At like a little computer watch?
No, at the guy next to me, whoever was on either side.
Really?
Right.
好吧，我在大学时真的很惨，因为我总是抄袭。所以我的眼睛很痛，因为我的脸朝前，但我的眼睛却非常努力地往左下方看。没错。盯着像手表一样的小电脑？不，盯着我旁边的人，无论坐在哪一边。真的？没错。
You were a habitual cheater.
Totally.
And was he hip to it?
Was he kind of like giving you a side wink and showing it to you?
No, no.
One of those big lecture halls, you know, I'd be like, my eyes would be like this and they hurt so bad.
But how did you trust that they knew the answer?
Do you know what I mean?
你是个惯性作弊者。完全是。他有察觉到吗？他是不是那种会给你递个眼色、让你看的人？没有，没有。你知道，在那种大型阶梯教室里，我就会，我的眼睛会瞪成这样，痛得要命。但你怎么相信他们知道答案呢？你知道我的意思吗？
Because any guess was better than mine.
Better than your brain.
Right.
Yeah.
I was just talking about this recently.
I never, I didn't cheat in high school or anything like that.
I never, I didn't in high school.
Not in high school.
因为随便猜一个也比我的好。比你的大脑强。没错。对。我最近才刚聊到这个。我从来没有，我在高中时没有作弊过之类的事情。我高中时从来没有。高中时没有。
No, I'd be willing.
I'd be willing to do poorly.
I had moments where I was okay, and then I just didn't.
Have you ever cheated in anything, Will?
No, I've never really like stolen anything.
I've never really, you know, one time this is a true story,
the only sort of really vivid memory I have of that is when I was a kid,
when a bag of chips was still 25 cents,
不，我宁愿。我宁愿考砸。我有过觉得还行的时候，然后我就是没作弊。威尔，你作弊过任何事吗？没有，我从来没有真正偷过东西。我从来没有，你知道吧，有一次，这是个真实的故事，我对此唯一有深刻记忆的是当我还是个孩子的时候，那时一包薯片才25美分，
and it was like a crowded thing at the convenience store after school,
and there were a bunch of kids in there.
I was probably 11, maybe 10.
And I was like, fuck it, and I had to catch a thing,
so I just took the chips.
And I felt so guilty overnight.
I went in the next day and I put a quarter on the counter at the store.
I'm going to walk down.
放学后便利店里挤满了人，里面有一群小孩。我大概11岁，或者10岁。当时我就想，管他的，而且我得赶着做某件事，所以我直接拿了薯片。我一整晚都感到内疚得要命。第二天我走进店里，把一枚25美分硬币放在柜台上。我要走过去。
Willie.
Yeah.
Willie are not.
Willie.
I know.
It ate away at me.
I couldn't like, I was like, oh, I can't.
威利。没错。威利才怪。威利。我知道。我知道。这折磨死我了。我不能，我当时想，噢，我不能。
Have you ever done anything that would justify you getting arrested that you've gotten away with?
No.
I did.
I was arrested.
You don't have to tell me.
You can just say, yes, I did get away with a couple of things I could have been arrested for had it been caught.
No, no, like, no.
I was arrested for that turkey sandwich.
你有没有做过任何足以让你被捕、却又侥幸逃脱的事？没有。我有过。我被捕过。你不用告诉我。你大可以只说：“对，我确实侥幸逃脱了几件如果被抓可能会被捕的事。”不，不，像是，没有。我因为那个火鸡三明治被捕了。
A turkey sandwich?
I told you I stole a turkey sandwich in college.
I was really drunk and the cops arrested me.
I told you that.
That is...
I don't remember.
I don't know if I've ever heard a more on-brand arrest story.
Yeah, yeah, I was in it.
火鸡三明治？我跟你说过我在大学里偷了一个火鸡三明治。我当时喝得烂醉，警察就把我抓了。我跟你说过那件事。那是……我不记得了。我不知道我有没有听过比这更符合他人设的被捕故事了。对，对，我当时就在里面。
Well, because...
And the turkey sandwich was definitely on white bread with mayo only.
Of course, yeah, it was wrapped.
You know, it was like in a 7-Eleven or what we called a white hen.
It was called white hen.
Yeah, sure.
And I was with my friends.
I was so hungry and I didn't have any...
好吧，因为……而且那个火鸡三明治绝对是白面包加美乃滋。当然，对，它是包好的。你知道，就像7-Eleven里的那种，或者我们叫White Hen的店。那家店叫White Hen。对，没错。我和朋友们在一起。我饿极了，而且我一分钱也没有……
money so I just stole the turkey sandwich I was really drunk we were eating out at front and the
cop just stands right in front of me he's like hey buddy you're coming with me and I was like
for a turkey sandwich and he put me in the back and I was friding in the back and I was you cuffed
did he cuff you uh I don't remember probably and um you probably asked for you said wait a second
you're not going to cuff me yeah yeah you're like use these and you produced your own cuffs
I'm pretty sure I need nipple clamps
And I think you have to
You have to cuff yourself to me
钱，所以我直接偷了火鸡三明治，我当时真的喝醉了，我们在外面吃东西，警察就直接站在我面前，他说，嘿，老弟，你得跟我走一趟。然后我说，就为了一个火鸡三明治？就把我塞进后座，我在后座挣扎着，你被上手铐了吗？他给你上手铐了吗？呃，我不记得了，大概吧，然后……你大概还要求说，你说了，等等，你不会要给我上手铐吧？对，对，你就像是，用这个，然后你自己掏出了手铐。我挺确定的，我需要乳头夹。我觉得你必须，你必须把自己铐在我身上。
Can you put the lights on and a siren?
I know my rights
My rights are you need to cuff me
I just start yelling
Yeah, no, it was for a turkey sandwich
And he took me to the station
And I had to sit there
Until somebody I didn't know
你能把灯和警笛打开吗？我知道我的权利，我的权利就是你需要给我上手铐。我直接开始大喊。对，不，就是为了一个火鸡三明治。他把我带到警察局。我不得不坐在那里，直到一个我不认识的人……
gave me 100 bucks to get out
And it's a long story
That's a crazy story
You got mystery bailed
Crazy waste of resources, though, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Crazy waste of resources.
That's what I was saying in the back seat.
给了我100美元把我弄出来。这说来话长。这是一个疯狂的故事。你被神秘保释了。不过，这真是对资源的疯狂浪费，对吧？对，对。对资源的疯狂浪费。我当时在后座就是这么说的。
I mean, it's horrible that I said.
Running your mouth.
Yeah, I was running in my mouth because I was drunk.
I was running my mouth and I said,
isn't there somebody, isn't there a worst crime happening on campus right now?
Isn't somebody getting like sexual harassment or something?
The next go-to is, my tax is pay your salary.
That's how, all right, there come the cops.
我是说，我说的话太可怕了。嘴里没句实话。对，我在胡说八道，因为我喝醉了。我在胡说八道，我说，难道现在校园里没有别的人，没有更严重的犯罪正在发生吗？难道没有人遭遇性骚扰之类的吗？接下来的一句就是，我的税在付你的工资。就是这样，好吧，警察来了。
I'm your boss.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Then they come.
I'm pretty sure you're supposed to pin me down on the floor.
Like hogtie, I think.
I think we're supposed to turn the light.
Lights should be a little bit lower, don't you think?
我是你老板。对。对，对。然后他们来了。我相当确定你应该把我按在地板上。像绑猪一样，我想。我觉得我们应该把灯光调暗。灯光应该再调低一点，你不觉得吗？
Shouldn't we have a glass of wine?
Where are we?
What's going on?
What about how I sent Shawnee,
I cut and pasted the top 10 vanilla ice creams out there.
And, you know, I just thought.
Number one.
Hagen does, of course, as always, it's the best one.
我们难道不该喝杯酒吗？我们在哪？怎么回事？话说我是怎么把肖尼叫来的，我复制粘贴了现有的前10名香草冰激凌。然后，你知道，我只是在想。第一名。哈根达斯，当然，一如既往，它是最好的。
So good.
Hagen does.
Although we like McConnell's.
Yeah, that's true.
McConnell's.
I think McConnell's was on the list.
Do they still make rum raisin?
Probably.
太好吃了。哈根达斯。不过我们也喜欢麦康奈尔冰激凌。对，那是真的。麦康奈尔。我觉得麦康奈尔也在名单上。他们现在还做朗姆葡萄干味吗？可能吧。
Why do you want some?
I just haven't had rum raisin in so long.
Well, it's got raisins in it.
Why would you want ice cream with raisins in it?
And rum.
Now, what do they do about the rum there?
Do they somehow take the alcohol out of the rum?
No, no.
你为什么想吃？我只是好久没吃过朗姆葡萄干味了。好吧，里面有葡萄干。你为什么会想吃带葡萄干的冰激凌？还有朗姆酒。现在，他们怎么处理里面的朗姆酒？他们是把朗姆酒里的酒精抽掉吗？不，不。
They're putting hundred-proof rum in the fucking ice cream
and selling it to kids.
Well, but I've really.
I want to know.
How did they get the rum flavor and rumme?
And there's still cocaine in Coca-Cola.
And the kids are like, the kids are like,
hey, you know, get another scoop.
他们把高度朗姆酒加进该死的冰激凌里然后卖给小孩。好吧，但我真的很。我想知道。他们是怎么做出朗姆酒的风味和酒香的？而且可口可乐里现在还含有古柯碱。然后孩子们就像是，孩子们就像是，嘿，你知道，再来一勺。
All right.
I'm sorry, surprise guest.
I know.
The guest, no, no, no.
I like that we said, you know,
we had a great segment before about being justified
because this guy is justified in a lot of stuff that he does.
I will say, he is a multi-em-ne nominated actor.
好了。抱歉，惊喜嘉宾。我知道。这位嘉宾，不，不，不。我喜欢我们刚才说的，你知道的，我们之前有一段精彩的讨论，关于“情有可原”，因为这家伙所做的很多事情都是情有可原的。我得说，他是一位多次获得艾美奖提名的演员。
he has a crazy diverse list of film and TV credits
that are just insane.
Comedy's dramas, recently, most recently,
I think that everybody was delighted to see him
in FX's highly anticipated series,
the Alien Earth franchise.
Oh, my God.
That's that Noah Holly vehicle.
他拥有极其丰富多样的电影和电视作品清单，简直疯狂。喜剧、剧情，最近，最近的一次，我想大家都很高兴看到他出演FX备受期待的剧集《异形：地球》系列。哦，天哪。那是诺亚·霍利的力作。
He's also, Noah Holly vehicle.
He was also in Apple TV show last year's Stick,
which has got a second season coming up,
Soon we're going to be able to see him with a crazy cast with Anna Taylor Joy
and Net Benning and a bunch of people in this new Apple TV crime thriller series Lucky.
Who is this tasty guest?
He's a guy who, you know, and the reason I say he's justified because he was also Emmy nominated for the show,
the show he started in called Justified.
他也是，诺亚·霍利的力作。他去年还出演了Apple TV的剧集《斯蒂克》，第二季很快就要推出了。很快我们就能看到他与安娜·泰勒-乔伊、安妮特·贝宁以及一众演员合作出演这部全新的Apple TV犯罪惊悚剧集《幸运》。这位诱人的嘉宾是谁？他是一个，你知道的，我之所以说他“情有可原”，是因为他也是凭借主演的名为《火鸡》的剧集获得艾美奖提名的。
You know him also from Deadwood.
You guys, it's the wonderful, and I'm so excited, Timothy Oliphant.
My friend, Timothy Aliphon.
Hi, buddy.
A little gentleman.
A year and a day.
What a pleasure.
Listen, I was on the set of Justified
你们也通过《死木》认识他。各位，他就是那令人惊叹的、我超级兴奋的蒂莫西·奥利芬特。我的朋友，蒂莫西·奥利芬特。嗨，老兄。真是个绅士。度日如年。真是荣幸。听着，我在《火鸡》的片场，
and I was working with Eric Roberts
and he's driving and I'm sitting shotgun
and I say
there was all those ND cops around
in the scene and we're supposed to pull out in the shot
and right before we rolled I said
I said I gave you 20 bucks
you just hit one of these, bump one of these cops
当时我和埃里克·罗伯茨合作，他在开车，我坐在副驾驶座上，我说现场有那么多群演警察，而且我们在镜头里应该把车开走，就在开拍前，我说，我给你20块钱，你直接撞飞其中一个警察，撞一下其中一个警察。
and he goes
I hit a cop once. It's not a good idea.
Yeah. And I was like, wait, sorry.
With your vehicle? He goes, no, I hit him. I hit him.
Oh, my God.
And he said, it was a bad idea.
They had me on the ground so fast.
And then from then on, I was just Eric the cop hitter, Roberts.
然后他说，我以前撞过警察。这不是个好主意。对。然后我说，等等，抱歉。用你的车？他说，不，我揍了他。我揍了他。哦，天哪。他说，那是个烂主意。他们把我按倒在地上的速度太快了。从那以后，我就成了“揍警警察”埃里克·罗伯茨。
Couldn't get the break.
And I said to him, ask him, how many times you've been arrested?
And he said something like in the double digits.
But then he qualified it because he said half of those were before he turned.
And I wasn't sure how to take that.
But I was taking it.
And then he looked at me and goes,
you ever been arrested?
这个外号甩不掉了。然后我问他，问他，你被逮捕过多少次？他说大概是个双位数。但他随后又加了限定条件，因为他说其中一半是在他成年之前。我当时不知道该怎么理解这话。但我就这么听着。然后他看着我问，你被逮捕过吗？
And I said, no.
And he goes, pussy.
Yeah.
I told him I was at swim practice.
You know what I mean?
It happened to me once.
Oh, I love Jason's story.
It's so good.
我说，没有。然后他说，个娘炮。对。我告诉他我当时在进行游泳训练。你知道我的意思吗？这事在我身上发生过一次。哦，我喜欢杰森的故事。太棒了。
Full pussy style.
It involves Monaco.
Yeah, I was arrested in Monaco
for being drunk and disorderly
in a nice little leopard outfit
fresh from the casinos
all banged up on, you know,
cheap champagne and a pocket full of chips.
标准的娘炮风格。这事跟摩纳哥有关。对，我在摩纳哥因为酒后滋事被捕过，穿着一套刚从赌场出来、帅气的豹纹套装，喝着廉价香槟，口袋里塞满了筹码，整个人嗨翻了天。
Oh, God.
Just got rocked.
That's the name of his biography.
So good.
Hey, but Sean, it sounds like we found a hack for you.
You ever do want the hog tie.
You just got to punch the cop in the face.
I just wrote it down.
天哪。直接嗨翻。这就是他的自传名字。太棒了。嘿，不过肖恩，听起来我们为你找到了一条捷径。如果你什么时候想要那种绑猪一样的待遇。你只需要一拳打在警察的脸上。我刚刚记下来了。
I just wrote that.
You got it?
Note to self.
That's why, listen, I'm here for you.
That's why I brought you.
Well, first, it's so nice to see you.
I've seen all of Alien Earth.
You're amazing in everything, but I just...
我刚写下来。记住了？备忘录。所以，听着，我就是为你而来的。这就是我把你带来的原因。首先，见到你真好。我已经看完了所有的《异形：地球》。你在所有作品里都棒极了，但我只想说……
Very kind of.
Will said that.
I love that show.
You're amazing in it.
Did you see Sean's face?
I knew that once I said that.
And he's like,
oh, blah, blah, right?
太客气了。威尔这么说的。我喜欢那部剧。你在里面太棒了。你看到肖恩的表情了吗？我一说出这话就知道。然后他就像是，哦，巴拉巴拉，对吧？
Yeah, such a good show.
It's coming back, no?
Hey, cool it, man.
Yeah, we start shooting in a little bit.
Thank you for asking.
You sound excited about it.
Yeah, we started shooting a little bit.
You know what?
对，多棒的一部剧。它要回归了吧，对吗？嘿，冷静点，伙计。对，我们过一会儿就要开始拍摄了。谢谢你问起。听起来你很兴奋。对，我们过一会儿就要开始拍摄了。你知道吗？
Tell me you guys aren't the same.
We shot the first season
In Thailand or something, right?
In Thailand.
We were in Bangkok.
Oh, wow.
And it was just a magical experience.
What?
告诉我你们是不是都一样。我们第一季是在泰国还是什么地方拍的，对吧？在泰国的曼谷。哦，哇。那真是一段神奇的经历。什么？
But.
I heard it was a nightmare.
I mean, there's a lot of tough conditions there.
I know people.
Don't put them on the spot.
Go ahead.
Oh, there's nothing better than listening to actors, bitch.
Come on.
但是。我听说那是个噩梦。我是说，那里的环境相当恶劣。我认识一些人。别把他架在火上烤。说吧。哦，听演员发牢骚没有什么比这更爽的了。来吧。
It's the name of my book.
Don't be afraid to bitch and other tips for young actors.
Well, that's so hot.
Look at us.
This group here, you know what they call it?
Like a murderer of crows.
and you're like a flock of seagulls.
You've got a little complaint of actors.
这就是我的书名。不要害怕发牢骚以及给年轻演员的其他建议。哇，太火辣了。看看我们。这里的这群人，你知道他们管这叫什么吗？就像一群乌鸦聚在一起。而你们就像一群海鸥。你们有一小群发牢骚的演员。
It doesn't have the air conditioning of the Warner Brothers lot down there.
Listen, I'm with you.
I'm getting to my bitch, which is, when we were there,
it was quite magical.
It's hot, but it was a magical, crazy, amazing place.
And the more you're there, the more you need to know it,
the more you like it, the same time,
you're like, I hope I don't have to come back.
那里可没有华纳兄弟片场那样的空调。听着，我跟你是一伙的。我要开始发牢骚了，那就是，我们在那里的时候，确实挺神奇的。天气很热，但那是一个神奇、疯狂、了不起的地方。你在那里呆得越久，你就越需要了解它，越会喜欢它，与此同时，你又会想，我希望我不用再回去了。
So for season two, they say, we're not,
we're like, we don't want to, please don't go back.
And they said, no, we're not going to go back.
we're going to go to either London or Budapest.
And no offense to...
But I was like, oh, please, London, London, right?
London.
And then you get the call from your agent and says,
所以到了第二季，他们说，我们不要，我们就像是，我们不想去，请不要回去。然后他们说，不，我们不回去了，我们要去伦敦或者布达佩斯。无意冒犯……但当时我就想，噢，拜托，伦敦，伦敦，对吧？伦敦。然后你接到经纪人的电话，说，
hey, good news, season two, London.
And I was like, can't shoot in L.A.?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It goes that click.
Yeah, yeah.
That quick.
It's like, fuck, I gotta leave...
Now, but...
嘿，好消息，第二季在伦敦。然后我就想，不能在洛杉矶拍吗？对，对，对，对，对。就这么一瞬间。对，对。就那么快。就像是，靠，我得离开……现在，但是……
Right, so what is that, what's your process of thought,
like getting comfortable with that?
Like, we are vagabonds, right?
Like, you start the process very quickly.
Okay, I'm going to be spending five months in a foreign land, in a hotel or rent a place, whatever.
It's like you immediately start thinking about, you know, logistics.
Do you have a wife and children that are you going to have to figure out how to detail?
Or whatever, your whole life at home is all upended.
对，那么，那是什么，你的思想过程是怎样的，如何适应这一切？就像，我们是流浪汉，对吧？就像，你很快就开始了这个过程。好吧，我要在一个陌生的国度度过五个月，住在酒店或者租个房子，随便什么地方。就像你立刻开始考虑，你知道的，后勤问题。你有妻子和孩子，你得想办法安排好他们的一切吗？或者无论如何，你在家里的一切生活都被颠覆了。
Start to bitch about that for me.
the wife and children
yeah
well you can start there
but just getting uproofing
35 years of marriage this summer
oh that's great
that's amazing seven really good ones
开始帮我发泄一下这个牢骚吧。妻子和孩子，对，你可以从那开始，但光是今年夏天要连根拔起35年的婚姻……哦，太棒了，这太惊人了。其中有七年真的很不错。
so we're
well right now we're empty nesters
yeah okay you guys are not none of
no I'm half empty
Jason's half I'm a
I got one more year until my first one goes to college
yeah so they don't they just
leave you. So just so you know, like if I did it again, I wouldn't have gotten so close.
所以我们，好吧，现在我们是空巢老人了。对，好吧，你们没有，都没，不，我是一半空巢，杰森是一半。我还有一个孩子才上大学，对吧，所以他们不会，他们就这么离开你了。所以你知道吗，如果我重来一次，我才不会跟他们感情那么深呢。
Yeah, that's serious. I've talked about it before. I think I tried to pick fights with my older
one, yeah, just so it wouldn't hurt so bad. Does she, oh, your oldest? Yeah, she's 19,
but she ended up going to school in town, so it didn't hurt quite as bad. Oh. Did she just
become like weeks before leaving just like, who is this fucking devil that's taking over my child?
Right. Yeah. Well, no, she's a, it.
She did a lot of, you know, as they do at that age,
they spend a lot of time outside the house.
So it's not, as somebody smart once said,
对，这很严肃。我以前也聊过这个。我想我曾试图和我的大女儿吵架，对，就是为了让分离没那么痛苦。她，哦，你的大女儿？对，她19岁了，但她最后在本地上学，所以离别没那么痛苦。哦。她是不是在离开前几周变得像，这个接管我孩子的该死恶魔到底是谁？对。对。好吧，不，她是一个，她。她做了很多，你知道的，正如那个年纪的孩子一样，他们在屋外度过大量时间。所以，正如某个聪明人曾经说过的那样，
you're not losing your 10-year-old.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Their wings are flapping well before they...
Yeah, and she's a particularly good kid, I will say.
She's a really nice kid.
She's a good kid, but...
Yeah, yeah.
There's a Tom Popper's, I think it's him,
你并不是失去了你10岁的孩子。对，对，对，对。他们的翅膀在他们……之前就已经拍打得很好了。对，而且她是个特别好的孩子，我得说。她是个非常好的孩子。她是个好孩子，但是……对，对。有一个叫汤姆·波珀的人，我觉得是他，
has a joke that when your kids leave,
nobody prepares you how hard it's going to be to pretend to be sad.
but even the best kids they tend to act up right before they leave right they tend to be like they got to
yeah it's part of their emancipation yeah it makes it easier to leave yeah so you're getting ready to
to go to london and you've got to like switch it all up you've got to kind of like start to prep
i'm i'm about to do the same for six months through Atlanta and i'm like all every day i think
about how's that going to go how is that going to wait a second hold on we're breaking news
here.
有个笑话是，当你的孩子们离开时，没有人会提前让你知道，去假装难过会有多难。但即使是最好的孩子，他们也往往会在离开前夕开始胡闹，对吧？他们往往会觉得他们必须这么做，对，这是他们获得解放的一部分，对，这让离开变得容易一些，对，所以你正准备去伦敦，你得把这一切都重新安排，你得开始做准备，我正准备为在亚特兰大呆六个月做同样的准备，我每天都在想，那会怎么样呢，会怎么——等等，等一下，这里有突发新闻。
No, well, it's got a big job.
It's super exciting.
Six months in Atlanta.
Yeah.
Well, how come I don't know about this yet?
Because you're not on my cold sheet.
I mean, I'm looking at it right now.
Can't you just like hit me with a memo or something?
不，好吧，他接了个大工作。太令人兴奋了。在亚特兰大呆六个月。对。那为什么我还不知道这事？因为你没在我的冷门名单上。我是说，我正看着呢。你就不能给我发个备忘录什么的吗？
But so like that, you know what that,
we've done it before.
So you know what that's like.
It's hard.
You're getting ready to go to and overseas.
What's the hardest part for you?
It's always the transition, right?
I don't know.
但就像这样，你知道那个，我们以前做过。所以你知道那是什么感觉。这很难。你正准备去海外。对你来说最难的部分是什么？总是过渡期，对吧？我不知道。
You tell me, once you're there, I feel like it's always lovely.
Yeah.
It is, yes.
But if you've got, like, Will's got kids back at home,
so they're not going to be able to be with you.
I forget.
Yeah, I didn't, I was very fortunate.
I got so lucky, I mean, partly by design
你告诉我，一旦你到了那里，我觉得一切总是很美好的。对。是的，确实如此。但如果你有，就像威尔在家里还有孩子，所以他们不能跟你一起去。我忘了。对，我没有，我非常幸运。我太幸运了，部分是由于刻意安排，
and partly just because I failed at getting jobs.
But I more or less got to work and live in L.A.
for the majority of my kids.
Was justified in L.A.?
Just, dead.
I literally had Deadwood for three years.
and then justified for, I think it was six,
and then we did this thing, Santa Cleary Diet for a couple.
部分也只是因为我找工作失败了。但我的大部分职业生涯基本上都是在洛杉矶工作和生活。《火鸡》是在洛杉矶拍的吗？只是，死木。我literally拍了三年的《死木》，然后是《火鸡》，我想是六年，然后我们拍了这个东西，《小镇滋味》拍了几季。
Oh, yeah.
They were all, they all shot here.
In Santa Clarita, I'll bet.
They were all insane.
I basically lived, yeah, I thought I was in show business.
But even in town, aren't you like, I can't wait to get home?
Oh, yeah.
By the way, even in town, you're like,
哦，对。它们全都是，它们全都是在这里拍的。在圣克拉利塔，我敢打赌。它们全都很疯狂。我基本上就住在这，对，我还以为我在娱乐圈呢。但即使在本地，你难道不会觉得，我迫不及待想回家吗？哦，对。顺便说一句，即使在本地，你也会觉得，
I gotta go to the valley?
Yeah.
That's with the real complaint.
Why can't I shoot at the Fox lot?
My kids were small.
It was great.
I just show up to work to take naps.
You know, that.
我得去山谷区？对。这才是真正的抱怨。为什么我不能在福克斯片场拍？我的孩子还小的时候。那太棒了。我上班就是去打瞌睡的。你知道的，就是那样。
So when my kids were really small, I was like, look, I'd just go to work so I'd get some sleep.
Yeah, yeah.
I know.
We used to have an office, Jason, and complain that I didn't want to go to my office,
and then I had another office for my company, and I'd go there, and I'd show up and see my partner,
and I'd be like, hang on a second, and I'd go and shut the door,
and I'd get on the couch and take a nap on my couch.
Oh, God, Will.
所以当我的孩子们还很小的时候，我就想，听着，我就是去上班好补个觉。对，对。我知道。我们以前有个办公室，杰森，你抱怨我不想去我的办公室，然后我为我的公司又找了另一个办公室，我去那儿，看到我的合伙人，然后我会说，等一下，然后我去把门关上，躺在沙发上，在我的沙发上小睡一会儿。哦，天哪，威尔。
I know, because I'm tired.
I was tired, man.
I know.
You know, dude, in my intro, like, I started going through your credits,
and I was going to say at the top.
You have so many credits.
You've done so much stuff of such variety.
It's insane, man.
我知道，因为我很累。我很累，老兄。我知道。你知道的，老兄，在我的开场白里，我开始盘点你的演艺经历，我本来打算在最开始说的。你有这么多的作品。你拍过各种各样的东西。这太疯狂了，老兄。
I mean, you're like, you're so unbelievably versatile.
And when you started as an act, well, first, let's get,
you were born in Hawaii and that you were raised in California.
But when you started, when you were first a young actor,
did you have like a particular lane you thought you wanted to go in?
Because you've eliminated the lanes all.
the dotted lines evaporated for you a long time ago on, on whatever road you're on.
Well, you're very kind, first of all.
我是说，你真的是，难以置信的多才多艺。当你刚开始作为一名演员时，好吧，首先，我们知道，你出生在夏威夷，在加利福尼亚长大。但当你刚开始作为年轻演员时，你有没有想过自己想走某个特定的路线？因为你已经把所有的路线都抹掉了。无论你走的是哪条路，那些虚线很久以前就已经为你蒸发了。好吧，首先，你太客气了。
And by the way, back at you because I just saw literally just a few nights ago,
is this thing on?
That's the title, right?
What a lovely, lovely performance.
Isn't he great?
Lived in and present.
Like you weren't, you know, that lovely thing where you're like,
this just must be what he's like, because, you know.
顺便说一句，我也要回敬你，因为我literally就在几天前刚看过，《这是开着的吗？》那是片名对吧？多么可爱、多么美妙的表演。他难道不棒吗？充满生活气息又极具当下感。就像你不是，你知道那种美妙的感觉，你会觉得，这肯定就是他本人的样子，因为，你知道。
And obviously your comedic work is off the charts.
So, so.
We've got it all.
My God.
It was really just a lovely, lovely,
beautiful, lived in performance.
Sean wasn't terrible in it either.
Look at Sean.
而且显然你的喜剧表演绝对是顶级的。所以，所以。我们应有尽有。天哪。那真是一场可爱、美妙、美丽、充满生活气息的表演。肖恩在里面的表现也不赖。看看肖恩。
Sean was delightful.
My God.
Which one were you?
From that,
yeah, that's a good question.
I was either Stephen or robber or something like that.
Or Jeffrey.
One of those.
肖恩演得很讨人喜欢。天哪。你是哪一个？从那里面，对，这是个好问题。我不是斯蒂芬就是罗伯特之类的人。或者是杰弗里。其中一个。
Now that I look at you, I'm like, yeah, you were there.
You guys all have this, by the way.
You guys all have the crazy range.
Sean, you're like, in Will and Grace,
you're like doing physical comedy at like the ultimate level of effortlessness
and then you're on stage doing like this incredible dramatic work.
Well, thank you.
Yeah.
现在我看着你，我就想，对，你在那儿。顺便说一句，你们所有人都有这个。你们所有人都拥有疯狂的戏路。肖恩，你就像在《威尔与格蕾丝》里那样，以终极的不费力气的方式在做肢体喜剧，然后你又在舞台上做这种不可思议的戏剧表演。哦，谢谢你。对。
Everybody's really good.
Jason, you also, you do the acting and you do the voiceovers.
Oh, you are an actor.
It's huge.
You are an actor.
Right, right.
Now that I see you, again, now I'm looking at you.
每个人都很棒。杰森，你也是，你既演戏又做配音。哦，你是个演员。太厉害了。你是个演员。你是个演员。对，对。现在我看到你了，再次，我现在看着你。
This is amazing.
I remember you from the Ozarks.
Everybody's really amazing.
Right.
But but but but it's sort of back to my question.
And I don't know.
Actually, you know what I'm going to say to all of you guys?
But Timothy, I want to hear from you first
这太神奇了。我从《黑钱胜地》里记住你了。每个人都真的很棒。对。但是，但是，但是，但是这有点回到我的问题上了。我不知道。其实，你知道我要对你们所有人说什吗？但蒂莫西，我想先听听你的看法，
because I listen to these ding-dongs all the time.
When you started, were you like,
because I remember, I moved to New York, I'll start.
I wanted to be a dramatic actor, I thought,
because I didn't know any better.
I didn't know anything about comedy or how you get to it.
It wasn't even, so I was like, I want to be a dramatic actor.
Did you have that?
因为我一直在听这群笨蛋瞎扯。当你刚开始的时候，你是觉得——因为我记得，我搬到纽约时，我先说。我想成为一名戏剧演员，我是这么想的，因为我当时什么都不懂。我对喜剧一无所知，也不知道该如何进入喜剧。甚至都不是，所以我当时想：我想成为一名戏剧演员。你有过这种想法吗？
Were you like, I want to be taken seriously?
I want to do important stuff.
You know, the stuff that we as young men think.
You don't think acting is comedy.
You think acting is drama.
Yeah.
Right, right.
Again, memory's not a reliable narrator here,
你是不是觉得自己想被严肃对待？我想做重要的事情。你知道的，我们年轻时脑子里想的那种东西。你不认为演喜剧叫演戏，你认为演戏就是演正剧。对。对，对。再次声明，记忆并不是一个可靠的叙述者，
but my favorite actors were actors who gave comedic, dramatic performances.
They were just, that's what I, you know,
I always felt like De Niro knew he was being funny in those roles,
even the most dramatic roles.
He must have known, right?
When he's doing taxi driver, he knows that's funny, right?
Right, right, right.
Doesn't he?
但我最喜欢的演员是那些能把喜剧演出戏剧张力的演员。他们就是，这就是我，你知道，我一直觉得德尼罗在那些角色里就知道自己在搞笑，哪怕是最具戏剧性的角色。他肯定知道，对吧？当他在拍《出租车司机》时，他知道那很好笑，对吧？对，对，对。难道不是吗？
There's some moments.
I wonder.
I wonder, that's a good question.
He must.
Right?
I always, I just assume when he's doing that, you talking to me, he knows that that's comedic timing
that's happening there, right?
Yeah.
有些时刻。我在想。我在想，这是个好问题。他肯定知道。对吧？我一直，我只是假设当他在那样做时，你在跟谁说话，他知道那是正在发生的喜剧时机，对吧？对。
Well, did you see him in King of Comedy?
Exactly, right?
Yeah, I mean, it's just incredible, incredible acting performance.
So when he did comedy and some people were like, I don't, wow, who knew he could do comedy?
I was like, raised my hand.
I was like, well, I think it was there from the beginning, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know.
好吧，你看过他在《喜剧之王》里的表演吗？没错，对吧？是的，我的意思是，那简直是不可思议、不可思议的演技。所以当他演喜剧时，有些人会觉得，哇，谁知道他还会演喜剧？我当时就举手了。我就想，好吧，我觉得这种特质从一开始就在那儿了，对吧？对，对，对。我不知道。
You don't, I still, I feel.
feel like Will Ferrell.
Oh, yeah, Will.
But Will Ferrell is playing these eccentric characters that are funny because they're eccentric,
but it takes great acting chops to be believably eccentric.
And I think this is the flip side, which is the best comedic performances are really dramatic.
I think the through line is always it's commitment.
Yeah.
你不会，我还是觉得。我觉得威尔·法瑞尔。哦，对，威尔。但威尔·法瑞尔演的这些古怪角色之所以好笑，是因为他们很古怪，但要把古怪演得让人信服，需要极高的演技。我认为硬币的另一面是，最好的喜剧表演其实非常具有戏剧性。我认为其中的贯穿线始终是投入。对。
Right.
And so you're committed.
We know, as long as you're committed to the bit, whether it's dramatic or comedic,
you have to be committed.
Jason, to your thing, like you can never wink, which is why when you see people who are doing stuff
when they're too aware, then you're like,
okay, I don't buy it as much.
But if somebody's committed to the thing,
对。所以你全身心投入。我们知道，只要你对这个梗全身心投入，无论是戏剧性的还是喜剧性的，你都必须全力以赴。杰森，就像你做的那样，你绝对不能眨眼，这就是为什么当你看到某些人在表演时表现得过于刻意、意识到自己正在演戏时，你就会觉得，好吧，我没那么买账。但如果有人全力以赴地投入到这件事情中，
you recognize that is feeling authentic.
And then one of the funniest things I think
is when people commit to being non-committal.
You know, like when you do,
like when you do really bad acting on purpose,
that's one of the funniest, I love that.
You know, when you see somebody doing bad acting.
For real?
你会认为那是真实的感觉。然后我觉得最好笑的事情之一，就是人们全力以赴去表现得“漫不经心”。你知道的，就像当你做的那样，当你故意把戏演得很烂时，那是最好笑的之一，我超爱这个。你知道的，当你看到有人在演烂戏的时候。认真的吗？
Yeah, like sing for real.
we'll be right back.
And now back to the show.
Timothy, do you know sing for real?
No.
You have this thing.
Thoreau came up with it years ago,
which is, it's so embarrassing.
对，就像认真的唱歌。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。蒂莫西，你知道“认真的唱歌”这个梗吗？不知道。你有这个习惯。梭罗多年前想出来的，就是，这太尴尬了。
Yeah, it makes your thing call.
So, like, if you're driving in the car
with a friend or whatever,
a song comes on the radio,
and if you say to the other person,
sing for real,
they have to sing that song
and they can't do any, like,
对，这会让你的那个东西起鸡皮疙瘩。所以，就像你在车里跟一个朋友或者随便什么人开车，收音机里放起一首歌，如果你对另一个人说“认真的唱歌”，他们就必须唱那首歌，而且他们绝对不能有任何，比如，
you say it's like Satisfashion by the Stone.
You can't do like, ah, I can't,
like you can't put anything on.
You have to do it as real as possible.
Yeah, and it's really.
uncomfortable it's so uncomfortable it makes your skin crawl like if i i had we did it in the documentary
too but i'll i had um well do it in the car one time and i couldn't even look at them it was so
i could it was horrible yeah it's the worst feeling driving with your pants off yeah and you're
你说是滚石乐队的《Satisfaction》。你不能搞成那种，啊，我不能，就是你不能加任何油腔滑调。你必须尽可能真实地唱出来。对，这真的很……不舒服，太不舒服了，让人浑身起鸡皮疙瘩，就好像我，我们在纪录片里也这么做过，但我有一次……我们在车里玩过一次，我甚至都不敢看他们，因为太……太可怕了。对，这感觉太糟了，就像脱了裤子开车一样，而且你……
it's funny you said satisfaction because i don't think of that as being like singing it for real
but it is no matter what you really are saying like this fucking man
on the radio.
You're...
Right?
Telling you how white
your shirts can be
and he can't be a real man.
你说的《Satisfaction》很有趣，因为我不觉得那是一首需要“认真唱”的歌，但它确实是，不管怎样你真的都在唱，就像电台里的这个混蛋。你……对吧？告诉你你的衬衫能有多白，而他却当不成一个真正的男人。
Like, you're in it.
Yeah, sing for real satisfaction.
Sing you have to think it's totally real right now.
No.
Yeah.
Don't make him do it.
Do it.
就像，你完全沉浸在里面。对，认真的唱《Satisfaction》。唱的时候你必须觉得这一切现在完全是真的。不。对。别让他唱。唱一个。唱。
You have to do it.
Go.
He's not doing it.
God.
It's so rough to do it.
See, because you just thought about it.
You just thought about it.
你得唱。来吧。他不唱。天哪。唱这个太折磨人了。唱这个太折磨人了。看，因为你刚刚想了一下。你刚刚脑子里过了一遍。
You're like, I can't do it.
I can't do it.
I'm looking at Will and I'm thinking I have to do it
based on that reaction.
Anything not to do it.
You can't.
Give me some lyrics.
What do I just know, look, this is not singing though.
你就像是，我做不到。我做不到。我看着威尔，心想根据那个反应我非得唱不可。为了不唱，什么都行。给我几句歌词。我只知道，听着，这可不是唱歌。
I don't know.
Okay, I can't sing.
Let's start there.
You can't do like a Mick Jagger impersonation.
No, you can't.
You have to do it.
I can do it.
我不知道。好吧，我不会唱歌。我们就从这开始吧。你不能模仿米克·贾格尔。不，你不能。你必须唱。你必须唱。我能唱。
No, you can't.
You have to sing it like you're recording it for real.
You have to do it.
Okay.
So I just was listening to this yesterday, and if I'm not mistaken, and I not said,
when a man comes on the radio, tells me useless information.
Is the guy on the radio giving the useless information,
or is he telling him how white his shirts can be?
不，你不能。你必须像在录音棚里录音一样认真地唱。你必须唱。好吧。我昨天刚听过这首歌，如果我没记错的话，而且我没说错的话，当一个男人出现在电台里，告诉我一些无用的信息。电台里的那家伙是在提供无用的信息，还是在告诉他衬衫能有多白？
Come on, everybody.
Who's telling him how white his shirts can be
and who's telling him useless information
just to drive my imagination?
Let me see.
It's the DJ.
He's yelling at the DJ.
来吧，各位。到底是谁在告诉他衬衫能有多白，又是谁在告诉他无用的信息来激发我的想象力？让我想想。是DJ。他在对DJ大喊。他在对DJ大喊。
When I'm driving in my car,
and the man comes on the radio.
Tells me how white my shirts can be.
About some useless.
What? What does he say it there?
God damn it. No, no, no, it's later. Hang on. Hang on.
Hold on. Hang on. Here we go.
I just love, my favorite thing about this song, by the way, is that he's, Mick at one point says,
当我开着车，那个男人在收音机里出现。告诉我我的衬衫能有多白。关于一些无用的。什么？他在那儿到底是怎么说的？该死。不，不，不，在后面。等等。等一下。等一下。等一下。我们来。我最喜欢这首歌的地方，顺便说一句，就是他，米克在某个时刻说，
because he's on a losing streak. And I just love the idea that Mick is having a hard time with the,
you know, like he was having a tough time. And that guy was really getting under his skin,
because he was, right? Yeah, let's be real.
Listen, he wrote it. I'm convinced as much as that guy sometimes seems like a character.
on a losing streak.
I know, but he's getting some depth, buddy.
I think there's some vulnerability there.
Those songs are too good.
因为他正处于连败低谷中。我就是喜欢这种想法，米克当时正经历艰难时期，你知道的，就像他正处于水深火热中。那家伙真的让他很不爽，因为他确实是，对吧？对，说实话。听着，是他写的。我坚信，尽管那家伙有时看起来像个角色。处于连败低谷。我知道，但他在展现深度，老兄。我觉得里面有某种脆弱感。那些歌太棒了。
Right.
I always wonder about people who write love songs and stuff
about heartbreak, and then they're like,
did they have this much heartbreak always?
Or like, what are they drawing on?
I don't know.
No one with a happy childhood ever went into show business, buddy.
Was your family in a show business?
对。我总是很好奇那些写情歌或关于心碎之类的歌的人，然后他们就会想，他们难道一直都有这么多的心碎经历吗？或者说，他们到底是从哪里汲取灵感的？我不知道。从来没有哪个拥有快乐童年的人会进入娱乐圈的，老兄。你的家人在娱乐圈吗？
Hire?
No.
Is your family in a show business?
Yeah, where'd the acting bug come from?
Yeah, how did that happen?
When had that happened?
It just was late.
It was a hunch.
雇员？没有。你的家人在娱乐圈吗？对，那你的表演细胞是从哪来的？对，那是怎么发生的？是什么时候发生的？挺晚的。这只是一种直觉。
I mean, yeah.
Just for you.
Nobody else in the family.
I thought this would be good.
If this doesn't work out, I got the ceramics to fall back on.
But where were you?
Where were you geographically when you went?
You woke up that morning and you had the hunt.
我是说，对。就你一个人。家里没有别人。我当时想这倒是个不错的选择。如果这行不通，我还有陶瓷制作可以作为退路。但你当时在哪？你做出这个决定时，地理位置上你在哪？你那天早晨醒来，有了这个直觉。
You listened to the hunch.
You went, I'm going to be an actor.
All right.
I'll tell you the chances of me keeping this short or slim.
But here we go.
Go ahead.
One, I will say that when I was a kid,
I really had a whole idea of fantasy of being in like show business
你听从了直觉。你心想：我要当演员。好吧。我敢说我能把这事简短说出来的概率微乎其微。但我们开始吧。说吧。首先，我想说的是，当我还是个孩子的时候，我确实对进入娱乐圈有着各种幻想，
or in comedy.
And when I'd say, I want to do that, like Steve Martin or something.
My mom, God bless her, she would always say things,
like you don't want to be like, you don't want to be like them.
They're like, you know, they're like on drugs and divorced.
You don't want that life.
You know, they're all divorced.
By the way, cut to years later, I was like, you're divorced.
或者想从事喜剧。每当我说，我想那样做，就像史蒂夫·马丁或者别的什么人。我妈，上帝保佑她，她总是会说这样的话，就像你可不想成为那样的人，你不想像他们那样。他们就像是，你知道的，他们既吸毒又离婚。你可不想要那种生活。你知道的，他们都离婚了。顺便说一句，镜头切到多年以后，我当时想：你自己就离过婚。
What the fuck?
Grew up in Modesto.
We're in Modesto.
Oh, you grew up in Modesto.
Yeah, so I grew up in Modesto, and then I went to college in L.A.
I went to USC.
I was a fine art major because I always drew as a kid.
And when I found out that was a major, I was like,
搞什么鬼？在莫德斯托长大。我们就在莫德斯托。哦，你在莫德斯托长大。对，我在莫德斯托长大，然后我去洛杉矶上大学。我去了南加州大学（USC）。我主修美术，因为我从小就喜欢画画。当我发现这是一个专业时，我就想，
you know, I thought I was getting away with murder.
Couldn't believe it let me do it.
I didn't know that that was a thing.
Like you could draw.
So you have a degree in drawing.
They'd give you a degree for it.
for that. Yeah. Yeah. You have one. I went to, I got one, like just, I finally got that a few years ago.
So you didn't finish. But, uh, I did four years, but I didn't get my degree until, you know,
你知道的，我觉得自己简直是赚大了。简直不敢相信他们能让我这么干。我当时都不知道还有这种事。就比如你还能学画画。所以你有一个画画学位。他们居然会为此颁发学位。为了那个。对。对。你有一个。我去了，我拿到了一个，就在几年前我终于拿到了。所以你当时没读完。但是，呃，我读了四年，但我直到……才拿到学位。
just a little bit ago. It's great.
I'll need to hear more about that. And then, yes, he actually gave me the honor.
It sounds like you bought it on the black market the way you're talking about it, by the way.
They, uh, I think it was like anything. It was like one of those COVID things.
So I was like, you know what? And my kids were getting ready to get their degrees. And I was like, I got to, I should, this is time to do it.
It was either a strike or a COVID, and I went back and finished up.
You went back to USC?
And then they gave me the honor to go at USC, yeah,
就在不久前。这太棒了。我得听听更多关于这事的故事。然后，是的，他实际上给了我这个荣誉。听你这口气，感觉你像是在黑市上买的学位一样。他们，呃，我觉得这就像任何事一样。就像是疫情期间发生的那些事之一。所以我就想，你知道吗？而且我的孩子们也正准备拿学位。我就想，我得，我应该，现在是时候去把它完成了。当时要么是罢工要么是疫情，然后我就回去把学业完成了。你回南加大去了？然后他们在南加大给了我这个荣誉，对，
and worked with the same professor.
It was a lovely experience.
Wow.
The great Ruth Wiseberg, who was my professor when I was there,
and she still teaches.
That's wild.
She and I got to do an independent study with her.
It was wonderful.
而且还和同一位教授合作。那是一次非常美好的经历。哇。伟大的露丝·韦斯伯格，她是我在那儿上学时的教授，她现在还在教书。这太疯狂了。我和她一起做了一个独立研究项目。那真是太棒了。
And then I got to go speak at the graduation ceremony for the fine art and all that,
which I thought was hilarious because all those kids had accomplished in four years,
what took me like 32.
And I was there to give them advice.
What were you thinking that fine art degree was going to afford you career-wise?
Like what do all these kids?
What do you take that into, like graphic design?
Because one of my daughters is that that's her jam.
然后我还去美术专业以及所有这些专业的毕业典礼上发言，我觉得这太滑稽了，因为那些孩子们在四年里取得的成就，我花了大概32年才做到。而我居然还去那里给他们提建议。你当时觉得那个美术学位能在职业生涯上给你带来什么？就像所有这些孩子们在想什么？你觉得这能用在什么方面，比如平面设计？因为我的女儿之一就是干这个的。
He's really gifted as an artist.
My eldest daughter is actually a student at SC right now.
And she's loving it.
Absolutely.
Congratulations.
Yeah.
Thank you.
她是个极具天赋的艺术家。我的大女儿实际上现在就是南加大的学生。她非常喜欢那里。绝对如此。恭喜。对。对。谢谢。
So should I encourage the 14-year-old to continue drawing?
Were there options explained to you there at the school?
Well, first of all, of course you have, of course you encouraged her to do what she loves doing.
Yeah, Jason.
You can't do anything else.
If it's not lucrative, God damn.
And I'll teach you nod.
is she's going to become a coder and learn Mandarin.
那我该不该鼓励那个14岁的孩子继续画画？学校里有没有向你们解释过有哪些选择？好吧，首先，你当然会，你当然会鼓励她去做她热爱的事情。对，杰森。你别无选择。如果这不赚钱，那真该死。我会教你点别的，她以后会成为一个程序员并精通普通话。
Fuck.
You know, yeah, what else are you going to do, right?
Keep going, honey.
She's going to code.
So here's what I understand now.
If kids who get like a Bachelor of Fine Arts,
they just have still have so many different directions they can go.
And they're thinking, and to some degree,
靠。你知道的，对，你还能做什么，对吧？继续画吧，亲爱的。她要去写代码。所以现在我明白了。如果孩子们拿到了美术学士学位，他们依然有很多不同的发展方向。他们在思考，而且在某种程度上，
I think they're very attractive in whatever workforce
because they were kind of just thinking outside,
box all the time and being creative.
Once someone gets their master's, they're going to be like a,
they're going to be an artist. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, got you. Sean, what's,
Sean, what's your degree in?
My degree is I never
我觉得他们在任何职场上都极具吸引力，因为他们一直在跳出盒子思考并且充满创造力。一旦有人拿到了硕士学位，他们就会变成一个，他们会成为真正的艺术家。对，对，对。好吧，明白了。肖恩，你的，肖恩，你的学位是什么？我的学位是，我从没
graduated, but I got an honorary doctorate
in music, yeah.
Oh, you never graduated? No, mm-mm.
This is breaking news. You've never, you have
buried the lead on this for all the more. I went four years
as well, and then I got an honor.
I didn't graduate high school, so you guys
got me beat. Yeah. Right.
毕业，但我获得了一个音乐荣誉博士学位，对。哦，你没毕业？没有，嗯-嗯。这是突发新闻。你居然把这事给隐瞒了这么久，对所有人都是。我也读了四年，然后我拿到了一个荣誉学位。我连高中都没毕业，所以你们几个赢了我。对。没错。
It doesn't show.
No one's ever.
It has not hurt you.
It just start drooling.
You're doing great.
You are doing great.
But wait, so you get this degree from USC in fine arts and drawing,
完全看不出来。从没有人。完全看不出来。这并没有对你造成伤害。你只是开始流口水。你表现得很好。你表现得棒极了。但等等，所以你从南加大获得了美术和绘画的学位，
and you're like ready to start, you know, drawing stuff or tagging bridges or doing something.
And then you go, at the end of all of that, you go, you know what?
You're in L.A.
And you're like, I want to be an actor?
Like, how did that?
I do think I had a certain amount of.
conscious thinking that I was wanting to put off a midlife crisis, that I was like,
whoa.
然后你就像准备好开始，你知道的，画点东西，或者在桥上涂鸦，或者做点什么。然后你在这一切结束时，会感叹，你知道吗？你身在洛杉矶。然后你会想，我想成为一名演员？就像，怎么会这样？我确实觉得我有一定程度的。有意识的想法，就是我想推迟中年危机，当时我想，哇。
Yeah, I really did.
I was like, I think my parents were split, and they were, my dad was going through his, his,
and I just thought, that doesn't look fun.
And, you know, there's, you always, you know, oh, I always wanted to do this, but I never did it.
So it became this.
So I was considering going to get my master.
and fine arts.
It's really kind of what I wanted to do.
是的，我真的有。当时我想，我觉得我父母离婚了，他们，我爸爸正在经历他的，他的，而我只是觉得，那看起来一点也不好玩。而且，你知道的，你总是，你知道的，哦，我一直想这么做，但我从来没做过。所以它就成了这样。所以我当时在考虑去攻读硕士学位。美术硕士。这其实就是我当时想做的。
You know, like when grandparents and stuff
would ask you, what are you going to, that degree,
what are you going to do with it?
At first, you're like, I don't want to be an artist.
And you see the expression on their face.
And then you start saying,
or I could do commercial work.
I could do, you talk about all the things you could do.
你知道的，就像当祖父母之类的人问你，你打算，那个学位，你打算用它来做什么？起初，你会说，我不想当艺术家。然后你看到他们脸上的表情。接着你开始说，或者我可以做商业工作。我可以做，你开始谈论你能做的所有事情。
But I really just wanted to be an artist.
And, you know, I was like going to galleries
and, like, you know, in L.A. in museums
and Chris Burton.
and Baldessari,
all these people were big inspirations.
But there was a bunch of things
I always wanted to try that were on my mind.
但我其实只想成为一名艺术家。而且，你知道的，我当时会去画廊，还有，你知道的，在洛杉矶的博物馆里，还有克里斯·伯顿。和鲍尔德萨里，所有这些人都是巨大的灵感来源。但有一堆我一直想尝试的事情一直在我的脑海里。
Like I knew I always
wanted to do stand-up.
I always thought about it would be fun to be an actor.
I thought, oh, it would be great to be in a band,
you know, things like that.
And I thought I should try to cross all these off
before moving forward.
Those all take a great deal of courage, though.
比如我知道我一直想说脱口秀。我一直觉得当演员会很有趣。我想，哦，加入一个乐队会很棒，你知道，诸如此类的事情。我想我应该在继续前进之前把这些都划掉。不过，这些都需要极大的勇气。
Well, what doesn't?
Well, yeah, well, yeah.
I mean, certainly standing up in front of an audience all alone with a microphone is sort of the zenith of balls.
Yeah, I was thinking of that on your movie.
I felt like they captured this thing that no one prepares you for when you do stand-up,
which is the moment you step on the silence that you created by is just...
Real quiet.
It's terrible.
嗯，有什么是不需要的呢？好吧，是的，好吧，是的。我的意思是，当然，一个人拿着麦克风站在观众面前，可以说是勇气登峰造极的表现了。是的，我在你的电影里就想到了这一点。我觉得他们捕捉到了那种当你表演脱口秀时没人会提醒你的事情，那就是你踏上舞台的那一刻，那种由你创造的寂静……真的很安静。这太糟糕了。
It's so quiet.
No one tells you that's going to be that quiet before you say a word.
Like the healthy respect I had for a stand-up.
and what they do before was huge.
And then it was just magnified the first time.
I remember the first time going down at this comedy seller.
And I was getting introduced as my character, as Alex Novak,
but I remember the first time going up there
太安静了。在你开口之前，没人告诉你现场会安静成那样。就像我对脱口秀演员的由衷敬意。他们以前做的事太伟大了。然后第一次经历时这种感觉被放大了。我记得第一次去那个喜剧细胞（Comedy Cellar）的时候。他们把我作为我的角色介绍上台，也就是亚历克斯·诺瓦克，但我记得第一次上台的时候
and trying to go up as a guy who had never done it before as well.
I remember Bradley saying to me, like, we're doing something different.
Don't try to rely on tricks.
You have to go up and do this as this dude who's never done it.
And going up there and standing there,
fucking, you're like, you just feel like it's so quiet
and you feel like, oh my God, I'm about to fall off a cliff here.
Yeah.
试图以一个以前从未做过这事的人的身份上台。我记得布拉德利对我说，我们做的是不同的事。不要指望靠小把戏。你必须上台，作为这个从未做过这事的家伙来完成它。然后上台站在那里，他妈的，你会觉得，你只觉得现场太安静了，你觉得，哦天哪，我快要从悬崖上掉下去了。是的。
And it's just, it's the best and the worst at the same time.
It's simultaneously just like the most terrifying.
So, yeah, stand-ups, what they do is just like, fuck, man.
And you tried it, Timothy?
Did you?
Yeah, did it for a little while.
Right around the corner from Comedy Cellar in New York
was a place called Boston Comedy Club, man.
这既是最好的也是最坏的经历。它同时就像是最可怕的事情。所以，是的，脱口秀演员，他们做的事简直就是，操，老兄。你试过吗，蒂莫西？你试过吗？对，试了一小会儿。就在纽约喜剧细胞拐角处，有一个叫波士顿喜剧俱乐部的地方，老兄。
Oh, yeah.
Of course.
Oh, you did, huh?
Yeah, yeah, I did.
Do you still remember some of the jokes?
I'll tell you some of mine.
Oh, Sean has a really famous first.
Sean's got a great opener.
哦，是的。当然。哦，你做过，是吗？对，对，我做过。你还记得一些笑话吗？我给你讲几个我的。哦，肖恩有个非常著名的开场白。肖恩有个很棒的开场。
Yeah, it's a great opener.
He's already asked me to sing.
He's told them before, but Timothy,
just respond to this joke.
This relationship is like, hey, Tim, sing for us.
Hey, Tim, tell us some jokes.
Yeah, perform for us, monkey.
He'll keep it up your ear.
对，这是一个很棒的开场。他已经开始让我唱歌了。他以前跟他们说过，但是蒂莫西，你只要回应这个笑话就行。这段关系就像是，嘿，蒂姆，给我们唱一个。嘿，蒂姆，给我们讲几个笑话。对，给我们表演一个吧，猴子。他会把这当耳旁风的。
Sean, why don't you wet the appetite?
Here we go.
My opening joke was, you know,
they say ballet is one of the most difficult things to do,
so I just say don't do it.
Oh, fuck.
And that's the joke, Timothy.
So, I mean, that's it.
肖恩，你为什么不先暖暖场？我们开始吧。我的开场笑话是，你知道，他们说芭蕾舞是最难的事情之一，所以我直接说那就别做。哦，操。这就是那个笑话，蒂莫西。所以，我的意思是，就这样。
Never gets good.
No, never gets old or funny.
By the way, and, well, I appreciate you call me Timothy,
but you know, you can call me Tim.
Can I call you Tim?
You can't call you Tim.
Sean, you as well.
Okay, great.
一点也没变好。不，一点也没变老，也一点都不好笑。顺便说一句，还有，好吧，我很感激你叫我蒂莫西，但你知道的，你可以叫我蒂姆。我能叫你蒂姆吗？你不能叫你蒂姆。肖恩，你也是。好吧，太棒了。
Bateman? Not so much.
No. Just you're close. You're close.
Do you guys, do you guys know each other a little bit?
Do you guys have a...
Yeah, we worked together for a smidge.
Uh, uh, not is this thing on.
Uh, this is where I leave you.
Close, close.
贝特曼？没那么多。不。只是你很接近。你很接近。你们，你们互相了解一点吗？你们有什么……对，我们在一起工作过一小会儿。呃，呃，不是《这会是哪出》。呃，这是《留下的日子》。接近，接近。
Close.
This is where I leave you.
And, uh, and you remember, because, you know, by the way, I'm at Chappikio's office.
That's where I am.
Oh, are you really?
Yeah, I needed a computer.
I guess you can't do your show if you don't own a computer.
Do you not own a computer?
接近。这是《留下的日子》。而且，呃，你还记得，因为，你知道的，顺便说一句，我在查皮基奥的办公室。我就在这儿。哦，你真的在吗？对，我需要一台电脑。我想如果你没有电脑，你就没法做你的节目。你没有电脑吗？
No, I don't.
It turns out.
Come on.
I didn't realize that.
Whoa.
Let's start there.
不，我没有。结果是这样的。拜托。我都没意识到。哇。哇。哇。我们从这儿开始吧。
Well, I mean, I got like a, you know, I got a phone and I got a thing.
That's all you got to do.
Oh.
We're backing up.
we're starting from here?
I don't buy it.
You don't have...
And you being an artist,
好吧，我的意思是，我有一个，你知道的，我有一个手机，我有一个小玩意儿。你只需要这些。哦。我们得退一步了。我们从这儿开始吗？我不买账。你没有……而你作为一个艺术家，
you don't have an iPad
with one of those little stylist
pen thingies?
No.
Wait, Tim.
You don't have a pencil in the paper,
you don't have a laptop at all?
Fucking baller.
你连一台带那种小触控笔的iPad都没有吗？没有。等等，蒂姆。你没有纸笔，你连一台笔记本电脑都没有？他妈的真是个大佬。
Wait, you really, truly don't have a computer?
I don't, well, let me...
Because I think honesty is very important
in this.
Sure.
Thanks for not lying.
We went, I had a...
We went and got out a old desktop
等等，你真的、确确实实没有一台电脑？我没有，好吧，让我想想……因为我觉得诚实在这个节目里非常重要。当然。谢谢你没有撒谎。我们去，我有一个……我们去搬出了一台旧台式机
computer that we
still have in the house
and plugged it in and started it up
and they were all USB things
and I was like I don't think I can
it won't I need to get adapters and stuff. Just for the purposes of doing
the podcast you tried to do. For doing this yeah
there's a lot of sacrifices that went into this
电脑，我们家里还留着的那台，把它插上电启动，结果它们全是USB接口的，然后我就想，我觉得我不行，它连不上，我需要买适配器之类的东西。仅仅是为了做你试着去做的那个播客。为了做这个，对，这里面做出了很多牺牲
guys and don't get me wrong I appreciate
I'm super honored
and it's a pleasure to be here I'm a big fan I listen
I don't listen but I read the transcripts
and it shows very very very good
sure sure it's better in written form
the chemistry comes across in the print
I remember getting a note from our producers
伙计们，别误会我，我很感激，我超级荣幸，也很高兴能来到这里。我是个超级粉丝，我听，我不听，但我阅读文字稿，而且它表现得非常、非常、非常棒。当然，当然，文字版更好，那种默契感在印刷品中跃然纸上。我记得收到制作人的一条信息
saying we're going to be producing
transcripts for Tim Oliphant
and we're mailing them to him
every day.
But wait, but Tim, you've never been tempted
to buy a laptop or a desktop
just to see the
landscape out there.
说我们要为蒂姆·奥利芬特制作文字记录，并且每天都寄给他。但是等等，但是蒂姆，你从来没有被诱惑去买一台笔记本电脑或台式机，只是为了看看外面的大千世界吗？
What's going on? Like all the different
sites you can go visit to
expose yourself to
Jason. Jason goes on a lot of sites and
exposes himself, is what he's trying to say.
Hey, gang, ever seen one of these?
Hey, gang.
Hey, yeah, hey, gang.
到底在发生什么？就像你可以去访问的所有不同网站，让自己接触到杰森。杰森经常访问很多网站并展示自己，他想表达的是这个。嘿，各位，见过这玩意儿吗？嘿，各位。嘿，是的，嘿，各位。
Wait, wait, this is so dope that you don't have a laptop.
Jason has 100 laptops.
They're all brand new just to look at baseball scores.
All this talk about AI and stuff.
Not curious to see what the fuss is about?
But you can do all that on the little phones.
I guess you can't, but you're always spreading and spreading
and clicking and spreading.
等等，等等，你没有笔记本电脑这事儿太酷了。杰森有一百台笔记本电脑。它们全都是崭新的，只是用来查看棒球比分。所有这些关于人工智能之类的讨论。难道不好奇想看看这到底是在大惊小怪什么吗？但你可以在小手机上做所有这些事。我想你不能，但你一直在展开、展开、点击、展开。
Don't do your fingers like that.
that.
Stop doing that.
It's spreading and sliding.
It's just like, uh-uh.
How about Chris Nolan doesn't even have a phone?
I'm like, so jealous.
I know one or two people without a phone.
别把你的手指弄成那样。别再那样做了。又是展开又是滑动的。感觉就像是，呃-呃。克里斯·诺兰甚至连手机都没有，怎么样？我整个人嫉妒死。我认识一两个没有手机的人。
It's the most exciting relationship.
If you know someone without a phone and you're like,
all right, so we're meeting at like seven, you know, dinner at seven tomorrow.
And then on the way there, you're like, this is so excited.
It's like being in high school again.
Just rolling the dice.
They said they'd be here.
Remember, we're old enough.
这真是最令人兴奋的关系了。如果你认识一个没有手机的人，然后你会想，好吧，所以我们在七点左右见面，你知道，明天七点吃晚餐。然后去的路上，你会想，这太让人兴奋了。就像又回到了高中时代。纯粹碰运气。他们说他们会在这儿的。记住，我们年纪够大了。
Remember, like, being teenagers and being like, hey, so you'll run into people, you'll go,
well, let's do something, and you had to go there.
And then you'd run into people, maybe they were there.
And maybe they were there.
And see them in the next place.
Where were you in the other place?
And the night would unfold.
If you go out at night, the night would just kind of unfold the way it was going to unfold.
还记得吗，就像当十几岁的时候，会想，嘿，所以你会偶遇其他人，你会说，好吧，我们做点什么吧，然后你必须亲自去那里。接着你会遇到其他人，也许他们就在那儿。也许他们就在那儿。然后在下一个地方见到他们。你刚才在另一个地方干嘛呢？然后夜晚就会自然展开。如果你晚上出门，夜晚就会按照它原本的方式顺其自然地展开。
What about directions?
What about directions? Remember when you used to have a map, a map book, the Thomas Guide,
or even one of those fold-out maps?
Or just a sheet of paper with the list of directions.
Are you going to turn left on such and such, then go a mile, then turn right,
on such and such.
Or you had to ask people for directions.
You know what's embarrassing, embarrassing about having a friend without a phone as you're going to meet them?
那路线怎么办？路线怎么办？还记得你以前得拿着地图、地图册、托马斯指南，甚至那些折叠地图的时候吗？或者只是一张写着路线列表的纸。你得在某个地方左转，然后走一英里，接着在某个地方右转。或者你得向别人问路。你知道有个有手机的朋友去见他们，最尴尬的是什么吗？
Let's say it's a 7 o'clock, you're meeting them at dinner.
You realize that we oftentimes are like, hey, on my way out the door, ETA 705.
And then it's like parking.
Like you're literally giving the play-by-play on the way there.
Yeah.
It's when you don't have that option, you realize how embarrassing that is.
Uh-huh.
But you do.
假设是7点，你们约好在晚餐见面。你会发现我们经常会说，嘿，我出门了，预计到达时间7点05分。然后就像是停车。就像你在去的路上进行实况转播一样。是的。当你没有那个选项时，你才意识到这有多尴尬。呃-huh。但你确实有。
You do have a phone.
I have a phone, yeah.
How about this?
I was talking about this the other day with people.
How about when you have plans, even with somebody you do want to see and they go, can't make it.
And the relief of not having to go to something is so great when somebody bails.
They're like, hey, I can't make it because then you're like, oh, no problem.
你确实有手机。这样如何？我前几天跟别人聊过这个。当你有计划的时候，哪怕是和某个你确实想见的人在一起，然后他们说，去不成了。而当有人放鸽子时，那种不用去某地解脱感是如此之大，当他们说，嘿，我来不了了，因为你会觉得，哦，没问题。
And you're thinking, like, oh, God, I get to stay home.
Found time.
It's money in the pocket.
Yeah, finding a 20 in an old jacket.
Hello, friend.
Hi.
Wait, you know what I want to say, talking about old friends
and working together makes me think,
然后你在想，哦，天哪，我能呆在家里了。白得的时间。就像口袋里多了钱。对，在旧夹克里发现一张20美元钞票。嗨，老朋友。嗨。等等，你知道我想说什么吗，说到老朋友和一起合作让我想起了，
justified, which was so good and you were so good
and it was amazing.
And over the, you said it was five years,
I didn't realize it was fine.
You did it with our old friend,
certainly Sean and my old friend,
Margotne Mardiall.
Oh, Margot's great.
《火线警探》，真是太棒了，你演得那么好，简直不可思议。而且在，你说那是五年，我没意识到那是五年。你和我们的老朋友，当然还有肖恩和我共同的老朋友，玛戈·马丁代尔一起合作的。哦，玛戈太棒了。
Who I adore.
It's the best.
It must be nice to have one of those,
would be one of those people that when people say your name,
everyone just goes, well.
Oh, guess what?
Guess what?
You're one of those people.
我崇拜她。太棒了。有这样一个人一定很好，就是那种当人们提到你的名字时，每个人都会说，哦。哦，猜怎么着？猜怎么着？你就是那种人。
I think you are.
You're one of those people.
You are.
Sean, start.
No, it's true.
It's true.
It's really true.
我觉得你是。你就是那种人。你就是。肖恩，开始吧。不，这是真的。这是真的。真的真的。真的真的。
I think you are.
Yeah, Margot Martin Dill, I mean, I will say,
what an absolute, just a legend.
I haven't had the pleasure yet.
Oh, Jason.
I'm a huge fan, though.
Yeah, she would love her.
Yeah.
我觉得你是。是的，玛戈·马丁代尔，我的意思是，我要说，绝对是一个传奇。我还没能有幸合作过。哦，杰森。不过我是个超级粉丝。是的，她会喜欢她的。是的。
She, I remember years ago, she did that,
when it Cresens.
movies, and so she didn't know John.
And he asked me to introduce him to her.
And it ended up being really, really good.
And so I said, hey, John Cresensky wants to call you,
and can I give him your number?
And she was like, okay.
她，我记得多年前，她拍了那部，在克拉辛斯基的电影里，所以她不认识约翰。他让我把他介绍给她。结果真的，真的非常好。所以我说，嘿，约翰·克拉辛斯基想给你打电话，我能把你的电话号码给他吗？她当时说，好吧。
And then she called me after she goes,
look, I told him I'm going to do his fucking movie,
so it better be fucking good or else this is on you
because you fucking force me to do this.
I was like, wait.
So good.
You know, Margo, I mean, that's so unbrand for her.
And she ended up being wonderful, obviously.
然后她打电话给我说，听着，我告诉他我要拍他他妈的电影，所以它最好他妈的拍好，否则这账就记在你头上了，因为你他妈逼我接这部戏的。我当时想，等等。太棒了。你知道，玛戈，我的意思是，这太符合她的作风了。最后她当然表现得非常棒。
But she's the best.
Yeah.
I had the pleasure of sitting next to her when she won an Emmy.
And it was such a lovely moment.
I remember, I don't know why it pops in my head,
because all that is what I spent a year with,
you know, that personality you were just talking about.
And such a, like, whether the camera was rolling or not,
但她是最棒的。是的。我有幸在她赢得艾美奖时坐在她旁边。那是多么美好的一刻。我记得，我不知道为什么这个画面突然闯进脑海，因为所有这些都是我花了一年时间相处过的，你知道，你刚才谈到的那种性格。而且那样一个，无论是镜头在转还是没转，
you just felt like you were getting this authentic, connected, amazing.
Just, it was so easy.
And then we were at the Emmys and her,
categories before mine.
So I just remember
that when they were, they
were sitting, I'm sitting next to her and they're
announcing the names and all that and then they say
你只是觉得你得到了这种真实、紧密、惊人的体验。就是，这一切都太自然了。然后我们在艾美奖颁奖典礼上，她的奖项类别在我的前面。所以我只记得当他们，他们坐着，我坐在她旁边，他们在宣读名字和所有这些，然后他们说
the winner is. And when they
said her name, she squeezed
my hand. Like I could have bruised
me. I get the squeeze
that happened.
It was the first
time I kind of understood
what the awards meant.
获奖者是。当他们念出她的名字时，她捏了我的手。差点把我捏淤青。我感受到了那股捏劲。那是第一次我某种程度上理解了这些奖项意味着什么。
You know, like I was like, oh,
that moment when that involuntary
like, oh my God.
You know, and then it was so moving.
Not much of a story, but it's just a moment that I remember sharing
with her. And then she forgot to thank you.
Did she thank you when she got on stage?
She did, no, she did.
你知道的，就像我当时想，哦，那种不由自主的时刻，哦，天哪。你知道的，然后那太感人了。算不上什么故事，但这只是一个我记得和她分享的时刻。然后她忘记感谢你了。她上台的时候谢谢你了吗？她谢了，不，她谢了。
She did.
She was classic.
We'll be right back.
And now, back to the show.
But Timothy, you know, Tim, sorry.
No, no.
So familiar.
Tea Dog, T-dog.
她谢了。她太经典了。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。但是蒂莫西，你知道，蒂姆，抱歉。不，不。太熟络了。茶狗（Tea Dog），蒂狗（T-dog）。
T-Deg.
Did you?
I remember that.
The other day, and I'm just remembering,
I threw my feed on Instagram.
I saw a clip of you telling the story about Deadwood.
It was so funny.
Can you tell what happened again?
蒂德格（T-Deg）。你吗？我记得那个。前几天，我正想着呢，我在Instagram上刷到了我的动态。我看到了一段你讲关于《朽木》故事的视频。太搞笑了。你能再讲讲发生了什么吗？
It was like the worst Deadwood story or something.
It was so funny.
I mean, I don't want to get it away.
And if you don't want to tell it, you don't have to.
It's already on Instagram.
We'll talk about it.
It's already, exactly.
But it's so funny.
就像是最糟糕的《朽木》故事之类的。太搞笑了。我的意思是，我不想剧透。如果你不想讲，你也不用勉强。Instagram上已经有了。我们聊聊这个吧。已经有了，没错。但太搞笑了。
It was so small.
Well, you know, milk stories.
You guys know the, the,
You guys have heard the Miltz stories over the years?
We've heard some rumblings, but I bet you Tracy is not.
Sean's sister.
She's not hip to the Hollywood stories.
David Miltch, by the way, his book.
太短了。好吧，你知道，米尔奇（Milch）的故事。你们知道，你们听过多年来米尔奇的故事吗？我们听到过一些风声，但我敢打赌特雷西（Tracy）没有。肖恩的姐姐。她对好莱坞的故事不怎么了解。顺便说一句，大卫·米尔奇（David Milch）的书。
Have you read his, I've read the...
No.
I don't read.
David Miltch for Tracy created Deadwood, amongst other things.
Yeah, NYPD Blue, Hill Street Blues.
Legend.
Deadwood.
And just a legend of a writer.
你读过他的，我读过……没有。我不读书。顺便说一句，大卫·米尔奇为特雷西创作了《朽木》，以及其他一些作品。是的，《纽约重案组》、《希尔街的蓝调》。传奇。还有《朽木》。绝对是一位传奇编剧。
And one of these guys who, like, you know, graduated first.
in his class at Yale,
had a heroin addiction.
You know, like a combination of brilliance and life experiences
that often don't go together, you know.
And so almost every day on that set was these kind of stories.
But we had a, what was it, the second season,
we had a storyline where I'm married to my,
而且是那种，你知道的，以全班第一名毕业于耶鲁大学，却有海洛因瘾的人。你知道的，那种才华与人生经历的结合往往并不常见。所以那个剧组几乎每天都在上演这种故事。但我们有一个，是什么来着，第二季，我们有一个剧情线是我和我的，
which it wasn't what really happened.
and in real life,
which my character was a real guy,
Seth Bullock.
But anyway, he was married to his brother's widow
and was raising his brother's child
as his own kind of thing.
So we had this whole, his kid and like a lot,
这与现实中发生的事并不一样。在现实生活中，我的角色是个真人，塞思·布洛克。但无论如何，他娶了他兄弟的遗孀，并把兄弟的孩子当成自己的孩子抚养长大。所以我们有整条线，他的孩子还有很多，
I think there was rumblings on the set one day
that there was some issue with the kid
as either his reps or his mother,
but David was really upset about something.
And I was like, I'm not going to pay it to him.
I'm just doing my thing.
All I know is that by lunch, it was a knock on my trailer door,
and I open it's David, which is unusual.
我想有一天剧组有传言说这个孩子出了一些问题，要么是他的经纪人，要么是他母亲，但大卫对某事非常生气。而我想，我才不理他呢。我只管做我自己的事。我只知道到了午餐时间，有人敲了我房车门，我打开门是大卫，这很不寻常。
And I said, what's up?
And he says, we're going to kill the kid.
And we're just going to kill him.
This is the next minute.
It's so good.
Such classic showbiz moment that happened after that.
He goes, I said, really?
He said, yeah, we're going to kill the kid.
我问怎么了，他说，我们要把这孩子写死。我们就直接把他写死。这就是接下来的情节。太棒了。之后发生了如此经典的演艺圈时刻。他说，我说，真的吗？他说，对，我们要把这孩子写死。
And this is the show, this is the part.
He goes, it's going to be great for you.
It's going to be really, it's going to be some really nice, some wonderful.
There's more room for you.
And a great, great moment.
Some wonder moments, these amazing moments.
He's going to be, and killed, and you'll be on his bed side.
And he, talking to him as if you're his brother and your brother and wonderful.
这就是剧情，这就是这部分。他说，这对你来说会很棒。这真的会很好，会有一些非常精彩的。会有更多属于你的空间。还有一个非常棒的时刻。一些奇妙的时刻，这些惊人的时刻。他会被，然后死掉，你会坐在他的床头。然后你，跟他说话，就像你是他的兄弟，你的兄弟，非常美妙。
And it's going to be good for the kid, too.
And, uh, he'll free them up for other opportunities.
And yeah, we did, uh, the whole season was this epic story that that art, that, whatever happened that morning turned in to the season.
That's so amazing.
That's amazing.
J.B. J.B. As an actor who directs, or how cognizant are you of being, of understanding the process that they're going through when you're giving a note?
Yeah.
I mean, it's all about, you're going to get a worse performance if you leave that note session with the actor and the actor feels bad.
而且这对孩子也有好处。这会让他腾出时间去寻找其他机会。是的，我们拍了，整整一季都是这样一个史诗般的故事，那天早上发生的那些事就变成了这一季的内容。太棒了。太棒了。J.B.作为一名既是演员又当导演的人，你在给演员提意见时，对他们正在经历的创作过程有多少认知和理解？是的。我的意思是，这一切都在于，如果你带着让演员感觉不好的心情结束了意见交流会，你就会得到更糟糕的表演。
Right.
It's all people's skills, right?
You've got to prop them up while you're telling them to be different.
Here's my, I did a movie with Larry Kazzen, just a dream working with him.
And he came up to me after, I think more than one take.
Yeah, it was a couple because he said to me, he said,
Tim, there's a joke there,
对。对。这全都是人际交往技巧，对吧？你必须在让他们做出改变的同时给予他们支持。这是我的经历，我和拉里·卡斯丹（Larry Kasdan）合作过一部电影，能和他合作简直是梦想成真。他在我拍完之后走到我面前，我想那是拍了不止一条之后。对，拍了好几条，因为他对我说，他说，蒂姆，那里面有个笑话，
but we wouldn't know it because you keep fucking it up.
Should we just move on, or do you want to try it again?
Hey, Tim, you get this, right?
It's a very usable, like, okay, lightning.
That was a good note.
I just had another, you just remember me,
I just did this play in New York,
and Lee Silverman, who's brilliant.
但我们不知道，因为你总是把事情搞砸。我们要继续，还是你想再试一次？嘿，蒂姆，你懂这个对吧？这非常实用，就像，好吧，闪电。那是个好笔记。我刚刚又有了一个，你提醒了我，我最近在纽约演了这部戏，莱利·西尔弗曼非常出色。
She's an incredible director.
and a good friend.
And she goes, at the first run-through,
it was a one-man show.
I did the whole thing, the very first time.
And afterwards, I go, I feel like I'm just saying words.
And she goes, yeah, yeah, it looks like that.
Oh, fuck.
她是一位不可思议的导演，也是一位好朋友。她说，在第一次排练时，这是一场独角戏。我把整场戏都演了一遍，那是第一次。之后我说，我觉得我只是在说台词。她说，对，对，看起来确实是这样。哦，操。
Wow.
Which was great.
Yeah, it was the kick in the pants.
But you were just so happy you got through it
and you didn't forget a line I'll bet probably, right?
I mean, that was the big test.
Yeah, but I mean, I needed to actually think about what I was saying.
哇。这太棒了。这太棒了。对，这就像是在屁股上狠狠踢了一脚。但我敢打赌，你当时肯定很高兴自己挺过来了，而且没有忘词，对吧？我的意思是，那是最大的考验。是的，但我的意思是，我需要真正思考我在说什么。
Now, on the other hand, I did a couple months with Soderberg,
forgive me for dropping a name.
That's what you do here.
Sure, sure.
Three months?
Yeah.
Not a single note.
Yeah, that's terrible.
另一方面，我和索德伯格合作了几个月，原谅我在这掉书袋。这就是你们这里的风格。当然，当然。三个月？对。没有任何笔记。对，那太糟糕了。
For three months.
That's terrifying in its own way.
Three months.
And once, I was in a car with him.
I was driving, it's just me and him, and he's operating.
And I got back in the car, and I said, well, what do you think?
and he goes, if on a scale of one to ten, that was a seven, maybe an eight?
And I was like, all right, cool.
整整三个月。这本身就够吓人的。三个月。有一次，我和他在一辆车里。我在开车，车里只有我和他，他在操作摄像机。我回到车里，我说，嗯，你觉得怎么样？他说，如果满分十分的话，那能得七分，也许八分？我说，好吧，酷。
So that was technically our one exchange.
No way.
One performance exchange.
But he's also editing, too.
No, it's interesting.
I was going to say, yeah, he is editing, but I was, I was going to say,
interesting, you mentioned Soderberg, because he is operating.
And when we were doing our movie with the, is this thing on with Bradley,
所以这技术上可以说是我们唯一的一次交流。不会吧。唯一的一次表演交流。但他也同时在剪辑。不，这很有趣。我正要说，对，他在剪辑，但我本来想说，有趣的是你提到了索德伯格，因为他在亲自操作摄像机。当我们在和布拉德利一起拍我们的电影时，这玩意儿到底开没开机，
and we're old friends, and he's also operating, right?
Bradley operated that whole film.
So he, and as you know, it's very close.
You know, he's like cameras in my face.
And he would start to roll.
We're rolling, blah, blah, blah.
And he put the camera up.
We haven't even started yet.
我们是老朋友了，他也亲自操作摄像机，对吧？布拉德利拍了整部电影。所以他，如你所知，距离非常近。你知道的，他的摄像机就怼在我脸上。然后他开始开机。我们在拍了，巴拉巴拉。他把摄像机举起来。我们甚至都还没开始。
And then he put it down for a second.
And he looked at him.
And he's like this far and he'd go, no acting.
And then the camera right back up.
And they're like, fuck.
Like pre.
And he was right.
I love that.
然后他把摄像机放下了一秒钟。他看着他。他离得这么近然后说，不准表演。然后摄像机马上又举起来了。他们就像，操。就像提前预判。而且他是对的。我喜欢这样。
And it was so disarming.
Like, you know, I had one time also I did,
I did one of these,
I did two of these Ninja Turtle movies years ago,
like 10, 15 years ago.
And we were in Madison Square Garden,
and it was produced by Michael Bay.
But he came in one day to shoot all this stuff at Madison Square Garden.
这太让人卸下防备了。你知道，我有一次还拍过，我拍过其中一部，多年前我拍过两部《忍者神龟》电影，大概10、15年前。我们在麦迪逊广场花园，那是迈克尔·贝制作的。但他有一天来麦迪逊广场花园拍了很多镜头。
We shot at a Knicks game, and then they cleared out,
and then we did this stuff on the floor.
And he decided to operate.
He wanted to do this one bit,
and the camera goes off, this action,
then up to me in the front row.
He goes, okay, reset, and it was like, chaotic and stuff was going,
and he's really on top of it.
我们在尼克斯队的比赛中拍摄，然后他们清场了，接着我们在球场地板上拍了这些内容。他决定亲自操作摄像机。他想拍这样一个镜头，摄像机切出去，动作开始，然后移到坐在前排的我身上。他说，好的，重新开始，当时场面很混乱，各种事情都在进行，他真的掌控全场。
He knows where everything is,
and he's got a crane going at the same time,
and he's operating, and he cameras down,
and he's like following along the ball,
and then he just goes right up onto me,
and just goes, say something funny.
I'm like, oh, fuck.
Literally like that.
他知道所有东西在哪，他同时还用着摇臂，他在操作摄像机，摄像机放低，他跟着球移动，然后直接摇到我脸上，接着说，说点搞笑的。我说，哦，操。真的就那样。
It was a nightmare, and I'm like,
and I said something super sweaty.
Farts.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
I can't wait to talk a little bit about,
well, you've got a couple things coming.
You've got this mini-series called the Five-Star Week.
那真是一场噩梦，我说，然后我说了句超级尴尬的话。放屁。对，没错。对。我迫不及待想聊聊，嗯，你接下来有几个项目。你有一个叫《五星周》的迷你剧。
The kids moved out.
I've been working more than I've ever.
Ever in my life?
Yeah, I mean, you have...
I guess I don't have to go to a tennis tournament this weekend,
so yeah, let's go.
Alien Earth is renewed for season two.
Stick Season 2 is been renewed for season 2.
孩子们搬出去了。我比以往任何时候都更加努力工作。这辈子从未如此？对，我的意思是，你……我想我这个周末不用去网球锦标赛了，所以，好吧，走吧。《异形：地球》第二季续订了。《贴地之季》第二季已经续订了第二季。
We just wrap that.
That was a joy of a gig.
Adventures of Cliff Booth, which is coming out around Christmas time?
Speaking of no notes, Fincher.
Yeah, talk about Adventures of Cliff Booth.
I want to know about this.
Yeah, what is it?
Is it a film?
我们刚拍完。那真是一次令人愉悦的工作。《克利夫·布恩历险记》，大概在圣诞节前后上映？说到没有笔记，芬奇。对，聊聊《克利夫·布恩历险记》。我想了解这个。对，这是什么？是一部电影吗？
The...
Yeah, that's the prequel to Once Upon a Time in Hollywood, right?
Is it prequel or sequel?
It's a sequel.
Yeah.
Sequel, but isn't it, is it the time before once upon a time in Hollywood?
If I get this wrong, it wouldn't be that surprising, but I'm pretty sure it's after.
It's after.
那个……对，那是《好莱坞往事》的前传，对吧？是前传还是续集？是续集。对。续集，但难道不是，是《好莱坞往事》之前的故事吗？如果我弄错了，那也不足为奇，但我很确定是在那之后。是在那之后。
Okay.
It's the Adventures of Cliff Booth, and it's later.
Gotcha.
I think we're in the 70s.
And so Fincher, light touch.
I'm not saying that sucks.
But I would imagine performance notes...
My favorite thing to do was after we'd finish a take
好吧。这是《克利夫·布恩历险记》，发生在更晚的时候。明白了。我想我们是在70年代。所以芬奇，轻描淡写。我不是说这很糟。但我想象中的表演笔记……我最喜欢做的事就是在我们完成一个镜头之后
is before he said anything, I'd say,
can I get one more?
If I could just get one more.
Once again.
Tracy, he's famous for many takes.
We're talking, right?
Yes.
I'm telling Tracy.
在他开口之前，我会说，我能再拍一条吗？如果我能再拍一条的话。再一次。特雷西，他以拍很多条而闻名。我们在聊这个，对吧？是的。我正告诉特雷西呢。
That's good.
That was good usage of Tracy.
Hey, thanks.
Yeah, so we would do...
Yeah, I did a scene, yeah, for like two days, a day and a half.
I didn't, like, I'd never done that anything like.
I felt like I was pledging a fraternity.
It felt a little bit like, oh, let's go again.
那很好。特雷西用得真妙。嘿，谢谢。对，所以我们会拍……对，我拍了一场戏，拍了两天左右，一天半。我从来没做过那样的事。我觉得自己就像在加入一个兄弟会。感觉有点像，哦，我们再来一次。
Let's do it.
Fuck yeah, I want to be part of this.
Let's go.
Is it technical?
Yeah, was it mostly because of technical and framing and light?
Like the composition thing?
Honestly, it's oftentimes multiple.
It's oftentimes a everything.
我们再来一次。操，我想要成为其中一员。我们走。这很技术性吗？对，主要是因为技术、构图和灯光吗？比如构图这回事？老实说，通常是多种因素。通常是全方位的。
It's, okay, on that moment, you know, maybe this.
And then when you lift your hand up, show me where it is.
Okay, now move it.
an inch left.
Okay, now down just to a half an inch,
lift it right there.
And you're like, okay, it's a lot of that.
So it's everything from when you lean forward,
好吧，在那个时刻，你知道，也许是这样。然后当你把手抬起来时，指给我看它在哪。好，现在移动它。向左一英寸。好，现在向下半英寸，把它停在那里。你会觉得，好吧，有很多这样的细节。所以从你身体前倾的那一刻起，一切都是如此，
don't lean quite that far, a little there.
So everything, it can get super, super technical visually,
but it can also get very, very specific about, you know,
when you do that, maybe it's more of an order.
Maybe it's more of a, like, you know.
So we'll sometimes be performance.
It's almost like doing a run of a play.
you know, like a scene, but you're doing it so many times.
不要前倾那么多，就那一点。所以一切，在视觉上可以变得超级超级技术化，但对于表演也可以变得非常非常具体，你知道，当你这样做时，也许更像是一个命令。也许更像是一个，你知道的。所以有时会是表演指导。这几乎就像是在排练一出戏，你知道的，就像一个场景，但你要拍超级多次。
You're doing it the master.
You're doing like 20 times and then you're pushing 20 times.
And so for a day and a half, you're just doing this scene.
What was the most number of pages you did on one day?
Was there ever more than three pages in a day?
I bet there was.
No, I'm very briefly in it.
So I just am showing up for this thing.
你拍主镜头。你拍了大概20遍，然后你还在推进拍20遍。所以在一天半的时间里，你一直在拍这个场景。你一天拍过最多的页数是多少？一天里有没有超过三页的？我打赌肯定有。不，我在里面戏份很少。所以我只是去拍这个东西。
And I don't know how many pages that was, but we shot it for a day and a half.
Wow.
But yeah, my coverage was day two.
It was kind of, it was fascinating.
And because you, so I loved it.
I really loved it.
And I think years ago when I was reading about him,
I just thought, no fucking way, life's too short.
我不知道那是多少页，但我们拍了一天半。哇。不过是的，我的个人戏份是在第二天。这有点，这很迷人。因为你，所以我很喜欢。我真的很喜欢。我想多年前当我读到关于他的书时，我只是想，去他妈的，人生苦短。
But for whatever reason at this point, I just was like, yeah, let's do 30 takes.
Great.
Oh, man, I'd sweep forward.
It's an experience, if nothing else.
But it throws you to a, there's a real quality that starts to happen that you don't expect,
which is you're doing it so many times.
it's hard to shut out the voice that feels like you're doing it wrong.
Yeah.
但无论出于什么原因，到了这个阶段，我只是觉得，好吧，那就拍30条吧。太棒了。哦，天哪，我会直接接受。不管怎样，这都是一次经历。但它会把你推向一种境地，一种你意想不到的真实品质开始显现，那就是你拍了太多次，
You know, and that's the kiss of death, right?
So you have to, so it's hard to, you also start to lose your instincts because,
I mean, it really does, it really is like a, you know, it's like,
pledging the fraternity here and they're going to break me down and I'm not going to,
I'm not going to crack.
He's talked about that.
He's talked about some of the strategy as to like, yeah, if you do a great take,
you know that feeling, right?
很难屏蔽那个让你觉得你演得不对的声音。是的。你知道，那是致命的打击，对吧？所以你必须，所以这很难，你甚至开始失去直觉，因为，我的意思是，这真的就像一个，你知道的，这就像是加入一个兄弟会，他们要击垮我，而我不会崩溃。他谈过这个。他谈到了一些策略，比如，对，如果你拍了一个伟大的镜头，你懂那种感觉，对吧？
Jason, you finish a take and you think, that just felt.
so money. The fact that
you're going to do 15 more after that
take, you start to go, maybe it wasn't that good.
I don't know.
You have to shut that voice out because you just have to realize
but he talks about
that sometimes he'll do
杰森，你拍完一条，你觉得，这感觉太棒了。事实上，在这个镜头之后你还要再拍15条，你开始想，也许没那么好。我不知道。你必须把那个声音屏蔽掉，因为你必须意识到，但他谈到有时他会拍
a bunch of takes just to get the actor to stop
acting, you know, because you just
run out of acting ideas
and then you just end up just saying the fucking lines
and that's sometimes
what he's looking for is I don't want
performance. Just say the lines and
let's get on. Just slide down the wall.
一堆镜头只是为了让演员停止表演，你知道的，因为你的表演想法已经用光了，最后你只是在说该死的台词，而这有时正是他想要的——我不需要表演。只要说台词，然后我们继续。顺着墙滑下去。
Just fall out of frame.
Right, exactly.
True.
You're doing too much.
But I feel like I've gotten, I mean, say this with a grain of salt,
but for the most part, my technique for the last decade or so has been memorizing the lines
and then memorizing them to exhaustion.
So I show up hopefully in that place.
直接跌出画框。对，没错。确实。你用力过猛了。但我觉得我已经掌握了，我的意思是，这话别太当真，但在过去的十年左右里，我的技巧基本上是先记住台词，然后背到滚瓜烂熟。所以我希望以这种状态出现。
So then to show up and then keep going, it's like you have to readjust your.
Sean's motto is always like, does this put me on the 405 this next day?
Like, you know what I mean?
What do they need?
Sure.
How do you expect me to act like this?
How would you expect me to act that well
when you've seen the craft service table
所以当出现并继续拍摄时，就像你必须重新调整你的状态。肖恩的座右铭总是像，这会不会让我第二天赶不上405高速公路？就像，你知道我的意思吗？他们需要什么？当然。你怎么能期望我这样演？当你看到剧组的餐饮桌时，
and we both know that's fucked up?
Yeah, terrible.
Wait, so we have to,
because I can't believe it's been an hour already.
I feel like I could talk to you about this shit
for fucking ever.
Talk about Lucky.
Lucky is about to come out this new series.
我们都知道那糟透了，你怎么能期望我把戏演得那么好？对，太糟糕了。等等，我们必须，因为我简直不敢相信已经过去了一个小时。我觉得我可以和你聊这些破事聊到天荒地老。聊聊《幸运儿》。《幸运儿》这个新系列马上就要上映了。
We have to mention it.
What's Lucky? Yeah.
So I got,
Lucky is also with the same preface
is the, whether it's a prequel or a sequel,
if I get some of this wrong, it won't be surprising.
Okay.
But I believe Apple, it's on Apple TV,
我们必须提一下。什么是《幸运儿》？对。我拿到的是，同样有个前言，不管是前传还是续传，如果我弄错了一些，那也不足为奇。好吧。但我相信苹果，它在Apple TV上，
and it's Ania Taylor Joy, Annette Benny,
that's lovely.
Tropper wrote it.
Yeah, he's the movie that you and I did together.
It's kind of a thriller.
Friends and neighbors, Jonathan Trapper, right?
Correct.
There you go.
主演是安雅·泰勒-乔伊、安妮特·贝宁，这很好。特罗珀写的。对，就是你和我一起拍的那部电影。有点像惊悚片。《朋友与邻居》，乔纳森·特罗珀，对吧？没错。就是这样。
So that was cool.
And then there's this, that was fantastic.
That sounds.
No, that's good.
Very good.
Great.
It's great.
就是这样。这很酷。然后还有这个，太棒了。听起来。不，这很好。非常好。太棒了。太棒了。
I think people are leaning forward.
Yeah, they're going to watch now.
Now I'm going to cut, I'm going to move on so that just leaves them wanting more.
And then there's the five-star weekend with Jennifer Garner and Peacock.
That's lovely.
That was.
Look at you.
You just go, go, go.
我觉得大家都在往前倾身。是的，他们现在要开始看了。现在我要切过去，我要继续，好让他们意犹未尽。然后还有詹妮弗·加纳主演的《五星周末》，在Peacock上。这很好。那真是。瞧瞧你。你就是一直拍拍拍。
I love it.
It's really awesome.
It's insane.
It's kind of fun.
And, yeah.
Thanks.
I appreciate it.
And then, yeah, the kids moved out.
我太喜欢了。真的太棒了。太疯狂了。有点意思。而且，是的。谢谢。我很感激。然后，对，孩子们搬出去了。
It was just, I think, there's a lot of time on the hands.
Yeah.
And then the, what was it, the Larry David thing, I think, airs after.
Curb your enthusiasm?
Before this comes up.
No, that 250-year thing.
Yeah.
So that was fun.
我觉得就是，有大把的空闲时间。对。然后，那个，是什么来着，拉里·戴维的那个节目，好像是在后面播？《抑制热情》？在这个之前。不，那个250周年的东西。对。所以那很有趣。
Oh, shit.
He's going to play at Trump's 250-year celebration?
No, no, no.
He's filling in for Millie Vanilly.
Oh, they filled it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then I'm just doing percussion.
Oh, good for you.
哦，天哪。他要在特朗普的250周年庆典上表演吗？不，不，不。他是去替补米利·瓦尼利组合。哦，他们替补了。对，对，对。然后我只是负责打击乐。哦，那为你高兴。
playing the Maracas?
I'm in that too, Tim.
Yes.
Yeah, yeah.
And?
Fun?
Yeah, super fun.
I think it comes out soon, like in June or something or July.
弹沙锤吗？我也参演了，蒂姆。是的。对，对。而且？有趣吗？对，超级有趣。我想它快出了，大概六月还是七月什么的。
Well, July.
Yeah, July, right?
Oh, Sean, do you want to talk a little bit about what you got coming?
No, tell me.
How was it?
Do you enjoy it?
Yeah, it was fun.
What did you do?
嗯，七月。对，七月对吧？哦，肖恩，你想聊聊你接下来有什么作品吗？不，告诉我。感觉怎么样？你喜欢吗？对，挺有趣的。你演了什么？
What was your scenario?
So the concept is Larry David did a show for HBO to celebrate the 250th anniversary of the United States,
and he put himself into historical scenarios to reenact them.
And mine was the Wright brothers, and it was,
me, John Hamm and Larry David, and
John Hamm and I played Orville
and the Wright brothers,
and he played Lawrence Wright,
你的剧本是什么？所以这个概念是拉里·戴维为HBO制作了一个节目，来庆祝美国建国250周年，他把自己放进历史场景中去重演它们。我演的是莱特兄弟，里面有我、约翰·哈姆和拉里·戴维，约翰·哈姆和我饰演奥维尔和莱特兄弟，而他饰演劳伦斯·莱特，
the third Wright brother, and he was complaining
about the middle seat on the plane that we just
invented.
And yours is what?
I'm OK Corral.
Oh, good, yeah.
Yeah, yeah. I'm one of the Earp brothers.
And Larry, the whole
第三个莱特兄弟，他一直在抱怨我们刚发明的飞机上的中间座位。而你的是什么？我是OK牧场。哦，很好，对。对，对。我是厄普兄弟之一。而拉里，整个
okay corral, Larry sets
it off. It's all, it was him.
It seems like plenty of
opportunity to hire either you or me, Will.
Our phone numbers must, we haven't changed
in a minute, that's weird. No.
Yeah. Well, um, let me just look that up. I'm gonna
check my junk mail.
OK牧场，是拉里引发的。全都是，是他干的。这听起来有很多机会可以雇佣你或者我，威尔。我们的电话号码肯定，我们好一会儿没换过了，这很奇怪。没有。对。好吧，呃，让我查一下。我去检查一下我的垃圾邮件。
Sean, I'm, it was more on you because
I feel like you should have said something on their behalf.
Yeah, I know. I'm sorry. You know what I mean?
You've seen them all the time. I do feel like
everyone in town has been on curb your enthusiasm. Will, did you do it?
No, you and I did not do it. You and I did not. I don't think he likes us.
You know, you know what? Larry actually said to me last, this is a true story so I can
said he said to me about six months
肖恩，我，这更多怪你，因为我觉得你应该替我们说句话。对，我知道。我很抱歉。你知道我的意思吗？你经常见到他们。我确实觉得城里每个人都上过《抑制热情》。威尔，你上了吗？没有，你和我都没有。你和我都没有。我觉得他不喜欢我们。你知道，你知道吗？拉里上个月实际上对我说过，这是一个真实的故事，所以可以说他说过，大约六个月前
go, how come you were never on curb? And I go, you never
asked me. Yeah. And he was like,
uh-huh. And then I said, I think I'm too tall anyway.
I did say that to him. We've had him on,
we've had him on the podcast, haven't. Yeah.
Yeah. I've never been in a Bateman project.
Should we just get to that right now? I know.
That's true. Sean, you and I've never been
他问我，你怎么从来没上过《抑制热情》？我说，你从来没邀请过我。对。然后他就说，呃-huh。然后我说，反正我觉得我太高了。我的确对他说过这话。我们请过他，我们请过他上播客，对吧。对。对。我从来没有参演过贝特曼的项目。我们是不是现在就该谈谈这个？我知道。确实如此。肖恩，你和我从来没有
in a Jason Bateman joint. Wait, you guys haven't
either? No. Wait, what? He's
directed like a bunch of things. Oh, are you going through a
canyon? You can't hear us right now? Are you?
Guys, can you hear me?
Do we listen? I hear you. I hear you.
Guys, I'm going to call you back.
I'll call you back.
参演过杰森·贝特曼的作品。等等，你们也没有吗？没有。等等，什么？他导演过一堆东西呢。哦，你们是进峡谷了吗？现在听不见我们说话吗？是吗？伙计们，能听到我说话吗？我们在听吗？我听得到。我听得到。伙计们，我要给你们回电话。我回给你们。
David, you send me a call sheet.
I'll show up.
I'm going to do, I'm going to put all three of you in one scene and then cut it.
And then I'm going to cut it later.
What do you mean cut it?
You won't be able to cut this?
It'll be so vital.
Speaking of vital, you're vital to showbiz, Tim Elfond.
大卫，你给我发个通告单。我会到场的。我要把你们三个都放进一个场景里，然后把它剪掉。然后我稍后会把它剪掉。你什么意思剪掉？你剪不掉这个吧？这太重要了。说到重要，你对演艺界至关重要，蒂姆·埃尔方德。
You are just an absolute gem.
And it's been awesome having you.
Dude, continued success.
I keep staying busy because it's so great watching you, dude.
Yeah, and give Karen and Christine their office back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Back at you guys.
Yeah.
你真是个宝贝。有你来太棒了。老兄，祝你一路长虹。我一直很忙，因为看你太棒了，老兄。对，把办公室还给凯伦和克里斯蒂娜吧。对，对，对。彼此彼此，伙计们。对。
It was a pleasure.
Thank you.
I appreciate you.
We look forward to it.
Five-star weekend.
Lucky, all this stuff.
Congrats.
And what a joy.
这是我的荣幸。谢谢。我很感激。我们很期待。五星级的周末。幸运，所有这些东西。恭喜。真是太高兴了。
What a joy.
The great Tim Oliphon, thank you.
You're going to get a round of applause.
Yeah.
I think that's the first goodbye applause we've done.
I think so, too.
Warranted.
Yeah.
太高兴了。伟大的蒂姆·奥利芬，谢谢你。你要得到热烈的掌声了。对。我想这是我们做过的第一个告别掌声。我也这么觉得。实至名归。对。
Gentlemen, it's a pleasure.
Likewise, Tim.
Thanks, dude.
Bye, buddy.
So, yeah, what about that, Tim Oliphant, huh?
I know, he's a good dude.
He's a real good dude.
He's easy on the eyes.
各位，这是我的荣幸。彼此彼此，蒂姆。谢谢，老兄。再见，伙计。所以，蒂姆·奥利芬怎么样，啊？我知道，他是个好人。他真的是个好人。他很养眼。
He's got talent.
I know.
What's not to love?
That's why it works so much.
And he does have a reputation that is,
he's one of the nicest guys.
That's his reputation.
Everybody loves him.
他很有才华。我知道。有什么理由不爱呢？这就是为什么他工作那么多。而且他确实有个名声，他是最好的人之一。那是他的名声。每个人都喜欢他。
Remember Margo saying how much she loved him back in the day.
Do they say that about any of us?
About us, about Sean and me, yeah.
I don't think so.
Yeah, they say about.
about John of me all the time.
You ever heard anything bad about me?
Let me just say, I would not look it up.
还记得玛戈以前说过她有多爱他吗。他们对我们中的任何一个人说过这样的话吗？关于我们，关于肖恩和我，对。我不这么觉得。对，他们一直都在谈论约翰和我。你听过关于我的任何坏话吗？我只想说，我不会去查的。
Where are you?
If you want to have a continued good rest of your day,
I would not investigate.
Don't dig.
No, you don't dig.
Everybody loves Jackie Bates.
Everybody loves.
You can find some naysayers.
你在哪？如果你想让今天剩下的时间继续美好，我建议你不要去调查。不要深挖。不，你不要深挖。每个人都喜欢杰基·贝茨。每个人都喜欢。你能找到一些反对者。
All bad.
No.
About any of us.
But boy, that's him all a fan.
Nope, you'd get tens across the board.
Did we forgot to plug.
We forgot to plug.
plug Hollywood Bowl?
全都是坏的。不。关于我们任何人。但是天哪，那是奥利芬。不，你会得到全场十分。我们是不是忘了宣传？我们忘了宣传。宣传好莱坞碗？
Yeah.
Really?
Oh, go ahead.
Maybe just roll the tape on that.
October 17th.
What do you do?
Hollywood Bowl.
You go to smartlist.com slash live and you get tickets.
对。真的吗？哦，说吧。也许直接播那个录音吧。10月17日。你要做什么？好莱坞碗。你去 smartlist.com slash live 就能买到票。
Sorry.
You go to smartlist.com slash live.
And you get tickets for the Hollywood Bowl, October 17th.
We're going to have some surprise guests there.
We're going to have some surprise guests.
Two or one?
A couple.
Okay.
抱歉。你去 smartlist.com slash live。就能买到10月17日好莱坞碗的门票。我们那里会有一些神秘嘉宾。我们会有一些神秘嘉宾。两个还是一个？几个。好吧。
You go to smartless.com slash live.
and you can get tickets for you or for a friend.
Sean, they're not free.
What do you do if you get them for a friend?
You have to.
Bye.
Well.
你去 smartless.com slash live。你可以为你或朋友买票。肖恩，票不是免费的。如果你帮朋友买票你该怎么办？你必须。再见。再见。好吧。
Smartless.com slash live.
Jason never chimes in.
Smartlist.com slash lives.
Smartless.
Will audio.
Smartless.com slash live。杰森从不插话。Smartlist.com slash lives。Smartlist.com slash lives。Smartless。威爾音频。威爾音频。威爾音频。
$5.
Smart.
威爾音频。威爾音频。威爾音频。威爾音频。5美元。5美元。5美元。Smart。
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjav, and Bennett Barbico.
Smartless.
Smartless 是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆贾夫和本内特·巴巴里科 100% 有机手工制作的。Smartless。